...
THIS IS A TEST.
TEST.
♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
REBECCA YAN: THE TIME HAS COME
[ APPLAUSE ]
JULIA TOBIN: WE'VE WORKED SO
REBECCA YAN: THE TIME HAS COME
HARD FOR THIS AND PUT IN SO MAN
JULIA TOBIN: WE'VE WORKED SO
HOURS TO GET TO THIS MOMENT.
HARD FOR THIS AND PUT IN SO MAN
YANNIS MESSAOUI: IT'S FINALLY
HOURS TO GET TO THIS MOMENT.
HERE: THE GAME OF THRONES FINAL.
YANNIS MESSAOUI: IT'S FINALLY
[ APPLAUSE ]
HERE: THE GAME OF THRONES FINAL.
9:00 P.M., HBO, SEE YOU THERE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ALL: SENIORS, CONGRATULATIONS
9:00 P.M., HBO, SEE YOU THERE.
AND WELCOME TO CLASS DAY!!!!
ALL: SENIORS, CONGRATULATIONS
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND WELCOME TO CLASS DAY!!!!
JULIA TOBIN: WE ARE YOUR SENIO
[ APPLAUSE ]
CLASS OFFICERS.
JULIA TOBIN: WE ARE YOUR SENIO
I'M JULIA.
CLASS OFFICERS.
YANNIS MESSAOUI: I'M YANNIS.
I'M JULIA.
REBECCA YAN: AND I'M REBECCA.
YANNIS MESSAOUI: I'M YANNIS.
WE'VE HAD A GREAT YEAR PLANNING
REBECCA YAN: AND I'M REBECCA.
EVENTS AS CHAIRS OF THE SENIOR
WE'VE HAD A GREAT YEAR PLANNING
CLASS COUNCIL.
EVENTS AS CHAIRS OF THE SENIOR
[ APPLAUSE ]
CLASS COUNCIL.
THANKS TO OUR DEDICATED TEAM, E
[ APPLAUSE ]
ARE ABLE TO HAVE EVENTS THAT
THANKS TO OUR DEDICATED TEAM, E
BROUGHT OUR CLASS TOGETHER
ARE ABLE TO HAVE EVENTS THAT
DURING OUR FINAL YEAR AT YALE.
BROUGHT OUR CLASS TOGETHER
YANNIS: OUR CLASSMATES
DURING OUR FINAL YEAR AT YALE.
SHOWED UP TO OUR EVENTS READY
YANNIS: OUR CLASSMATES
GO, BUT LET'S NOT FORGET SOME
SHOWED UP TO OUR EVENTS READY
THINGS THAT WHAT WENT DOWN
GO, BUT LET'S NOT FORGET SOME
BEHIND THE SCENES. >> LIKE
THINGS THAT WHAT WENT DOWN
REMEMBER WHEN OUR TREASURER
BEHIND THE SCENES. >> LIKE
BOUGHT TEN EXTRA KEGS FOR OUR
REMEMBER WHEN OUR TREASURER
EVENT FOR PEACE OF MIND.
BOUGHT TEN EXTRA KEGS FOR OUR
EVEN DEAN CHUN ASKED, WHAT ARE
EVENT FOR PEACE OF MIND.
YOU GOIG TO DO WITH ALL THIS
EVEN DEAN CHUN ASKED, WHAT ARE
LEFTOVER BEER?
YOU GOIG TO DO WITH ALL THIS
>> DON'T WORRY, DEAN CHUN, WE
LEFTOVER BEER?
FIGURED OUT A SOLUTION.
>> DON'T WORRY, DEAN CHUN, WE
>> DURING OUR TIME HERE AT YALE,
FIGURED OUT A SOLUTION.
WE SAW MANY DIFFERENT THINGS.
>> DURING OUR TIME HERE AT YALE,
>> LET'S UNPACK THAT.
WE SAW MANY DIFFERENT THINGS.
YANNIS: ON OUR VERY FIRST DAY,
>> LET'S UNPACK THAT.
WE SHOWED UP AS BRIGHT EYED
YANNIS: ON OUR VERY FIRST DAY,
FIRST-YEARS, FRESH OUT OF HIGH
WE SHOWED UP AS BRIGHT EYED
SCHOOL, LANYARDS AND NOTEBOOKS
FIRST-YEARS, FRESH OUT OF HIGH
IN HAND. FAST FORWARD TO SENIOR
SCHOOL, LANYARDS AND NOTEBOOKS
YEAR, AND OUR FIRST DAY LOOK IS
IN HAND. FAST FORWARD TO SENIOR
NO BACKPACK, NO SLEEP, AND
YEAR, AND OUR FIRST DAY LOOK IS
CHECKING THE LOCATION OF OUR
NO BACKPACK, NO SLEEP, AND
CLASSES WHILE WE WERE WALKING TO
CHECKING THE LOCATION OF OUR
THEM.
CLASSES WHILE WE WERE WALKING TO
REBECCA: WE WENT FROM HAVING
THEM.
CAMP YALE FRIENDS TO REAL
REBECCA: WE WENT FROM HAVING
FRIENDS.
CAMP YALE FRIENDS TO REAL
AND WHILE WE LOST SASHA PUP, WE
FRIENDS.
GAINED A NEW HANDSOME DAN.
AND WHILE WE LOST SASHA PUP, WE
JULIA: OUR CLASS FINALLY BROKE
GAINED A NEW HANDSOME DAN.
THE HARVARD YALE LOSING STREAK
JULIA: OUR CLASS FINALLY BROKE
WE STORMED THE YALE BOWL AND
THE HARVARD YALE LOSING STREAK
HARVARD STADIUM.
WE STORMED THE YALE BOWL AND
AND TOOK SELFIES WITH PRESIDENT
HARVARD STADIUM.
SALOVEY WHO SEEMED TO LOVE
AND TOOK SELFIES WITH PRESIDENT
BEATING HARVARD EVEN MORE THAN
SALOVEY WHO SEEMED TO LOVE
WE DID.
BEATING HARVARD EVEN MORE THAN
THOUGHT THE 12 COLLEGE CHALLEN
WE DID.
WAS HARD, WELL GUESS WHAT, THE
THOUGHT THE 12 COLLEGE CHALLEN
14 COLLEGE CHALLENGE IS EVEN
WAS HARD, WELL GUESS WHAT, THE
HARDER.
14 COLLEGE CHALLENGE IS EVEN
JULIA: AS WE REFLECT ON OUR TI
HARDER.
AT YALE, WE REALIZE THAT THERE
JULIA: AS WE REFLECT ON OUR TI
ARE SOME THINGS WE JUST PROBABLY
AT YALE, WE REALIZE THAT THERE
WON'T MISS.
ARE SOME THINGS WE JUST PROBABLY
LIKE HEARING, "RESIDENTIAL
WON'T MISS.
COLLEGES ARE A MICROCOSM OF THE
LIKE HEARING, "RESIDENTIAL
YALE COMMUNITY."
COLLEGES ARE A MICROCOSM OF THE
REBECCA: OR REALIZING YOU'RE
YALE COMMUNITY."
HAVING A VERY BAD NIGHT WHEN
REBECCA: OR REALIZING YOU'RE
YOU'RE FORCED TO MOVE IN
HAVING A VERY BAD NIGHT WHEN
STERLING TO BASS LIBRARY AT
YOU'RE FORCED TO MOVE IN
11:45:00 P.M.
STERLING TO BASS LIBRARY AT
YANNIS: AND THEN YOU'VE GOT TO
11:45:00 P.M.
GO BACK TO YOUR TWIN XL BED,
YANNIS: AND THEN YOU'VE GOT TO
WHICH IS NEVER FUN, ESPECIALLY
GO BACK TO YOUR TWIN XL BED,
WHEN YOU'RE 6'3".
WHICH IS NEVER FUN, ESPECIALLY
REBECCA: I KNOW I WON'T MISS
WHEN YOU'RE 6'3".
STRUGGLING TO OPEN EVERY GATE AT
REBECCA: I KNOW I WON'T MISS
YALE.
STRUGGLING TO OPEN EVERY GATE AT
WHY ARE THEY SO HEAVY?
YALE.
JULIA: AND THEN THERE'S ALWAYS
WHY ARE THEY SO HEAVY?
MIDTERM SEASON, WHICH
JULIA: AND THEN THERE'S ALWAYS
ESSENTIALLY MEANS THE ENTIRE
MIDTERM SEASON, WHICH
SEMESTER.
ESSENTIALLY MEANS THE ENTIRE
>> WHILE WE WON'T MISS THE
SEMESTER.
MASSIVE GATES, SO MUCH WE WILL
>> WHILE WE WON'T MISS THE
MISS.
MASSIVE GATES, SO MUCH WE WILL
>> LIVING A BLOCK AWAY FROM YOUR
MISS.
CLOSEST FRIENDS, AND THE PEOPLE
>> LIVING A BLOCK AWAY FROM YOUR
WHO MAKE IT FUN AND WHY WE LOVE
CLOSEST FRIENDS, AND THE PEOPLE
YALE.
WHO MAKE IT FUN AND WHY WE LOVE
>> NO MORE DO I FEEL MORE
YALE.
CONNECTED TO THE CLASS THAN
>> NO MORE DO I FEEL MORE
WEDNESDAYS AT 1:00 A.M. WHEN WE
CONNECTED TO THE CLASS THAN
ALL CHANT LIVING ON A PRAYER
WEDNESDAYS AT 1:00 A.M. WHEN WE
TOGETHER.
ALL CHANT LIVING ON A PRAYER
WE WON'T FORGET THE DAYS WHEN
TOGETHER.
THE TEMPERATURE IS FINALLY ABOV
WE WON'T FORGET THE DAYS WHEN
FREEZING, AND YALE ACTUALLY
THE TEMPERATURE IS FINALLY ABOV
LOOKS LIKE THE BROCHURE. WE
FREEZING, AND YALE ACTUALLY
CRAWL OUT OF HIBERNATION, ALL
LOOKS LIKE THE BROCHURE. WE
SIT ON CROSS CAMPUS, AND PRETEN
CRAWL OUT OF HIBERNATION, ALL
TO DO WORK.
SIT ON CROSS CAMPUS, AND PRETEN
JULIA: I WILL MISS OUR YALE LA
TO DO WORK.
WHEN WE GO TO THE BUTTERY TO
JULIA: I WILL MISS OUR YALE LA
GRAB A $1 QUESADILLA.
WHEN WE GO TO THE BUTTERY TO
OR SIT IN G-HEAV EATING WITH OUR
GRAB A $1 QUESADILLA.
FRIENDS.
OR SIT IN G-HEAV EATING WITH OUR
>> OR WITH FINDING THE PEOPLE
FRIENDS.
THAT BECOME OUR CLOSEST
>> OR WITH FINDING THE PEOPLE
FRIENDS.
THAT BECOME OUR CLOSEST
THAT'S THE PEOPLE WITH ME ON
FRIENDS.
STAGE.
THAT'S THE PEOPLE WITH ME ON
>> WE KNOW THAT YALE IS MAKING
STAGE.
US BE THE PEOPLE WE WANT TO BE.
>> WE KNOW THAT YALE IS MAKING
IN AN OPEN ENVIRONMENT, WE ARE
US BE THE PEOPLE WE WANT TO BE.
SHARING OUR EXPERIENCES.
IN AN OPEN ENVIRONMENT, WE ARE
>> ALTHOUGH YALE WAS
SHARING OUR EXPERIENCES.
CHALLENGING, WE HAD FAMILY,
>> ALTHOUGH YALE WAS
FRIENDS, AND FACULTY WHO HELPED
CHALLENGING, WE HAD FAMILY,
US MAKE IT THROUGH.
FRIENDS, AND FACULTY WHO HELPED
WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THE TIME
US MAKE IT THROUGH.
NOW TO THANK YOU ALL.
WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THE TIME
[ APPLAUSE ]
NOW TO THANK YOU ALL.
YANNIS: TODAY, WE CELEBRATE WH
[ APPLAUSE ]
WE HAVE ACHIEVED. TOMORROW, WE
YANNIS: TODAY, WE CELEBRATE WH
LOOK FORWARD TO NEW POSSIBILITI.
WE HAVE ACHIEVED. TOMORROW, WE
CONGRATULATIONS TO US ALL.
LOOK FORWARD TO NEW POSSIBILITI.
WE SHOULD BE SO PROUD OF
CONGRATULATIONS TO US ALL.
OURSELVES FOR MAKING IT TO THIS
WE SHOULD BE SO PROUD OF
DAY.
OURSELVES FOR MAKING IT TO THIS
[ APPLAUSE ]
DAY.
>> HERE'S TO THE CLASS OF 2019!
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> HELLO CLASS OF 2019.
SHUYU SONG: I'M SHUYU. HAROLD
EKEH: AND I'M HAROLD. SHUYU: WE
ARE MEMBERS OF THIS YEAR'S CLASS
DAY PLANNING COMMITTEE.
YOU WILL MEET ALL THE REST OF
THE MEMBERS THROUGHOUT THIS
AFTERNOON'S CEREMONY.
BUT RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE THE HON
OF INTRODUCING OUR CLASS DAY
SPEAK SPEAKER.
[ APPLAUSE ]
HAROLD: YEAH, IT'S INCREDIBLE.
SO, WE HAVE WITH US TODAY AN
ACCLAIMED WRITER, AN
INSPIRING GLOBAL CITIZEN WHOSE
WORDS, TEACHING, AND SOCIAL
ACTIVISM HAVE HAD AN INDELIBLE
IMPACT ON THE DIASPORA AND
BROADER CONTEMPORARY CULTURE.
SHE IS KNOWN FOR HER
AWARD-WINNING NOVELS,
NON-FICTION, HER RIVETING TED
TALKS, AND MUCH MORE.
SHE WAS BORN IN NIGERIA,
WHERE HER FATHER WAS A PROFESS
AND HER MOTHER WAS THE FIRST
FEMALE REGISTRAR. SHE STUDIED
MEDICINE FOR A YEAR AT NSUKKA
AND THEN LEFT FOR THE UNITED
STATES AT THE AGE OF 19 TO
CONTINUE HER EDUCATION ON A
DIFFERENT PATH.
SHUYU: SHE GRADUATED SUMMA CUM
LAUDE FROM EASTERN CONNECTICUT
STATE UNIVERSITY WITH A DEGREE
IN COMMUNICATION AND POLITICAL
SCIENCE.
SHE ALSO HAS A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN CREATIVE WRITING FROM JOHNS
HOPKINS UNIVERSITY AND A MASTER
OF ARTS IN AFRICAN HISTORY FROM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
HER WORK HAS BEEN TRANSLATED
INTO OVER 30 LANGUAGES.
AND HER NOVELS HAVE WON
PRESTIGIOUS PRIZES IN LITERATUR.
HER 2013 NOVEL "AMERICANAH" WO
THE US NATIONAL BOOK CRITICS
CIRCLE AWARD, AND WAS NAMED ONE
OF THE NEW YORK TIMES TOP TEN
BEST BOOKS OF 2013.
IN 2008, SHE RECEIVED A
MACARTHUR "GENIUS GRANT"
FELLOWSHIP, AND IN 2015 SHE WAS
NAMED ONE OF TIME MAGAZINE'S 10
MOST INFLUENTIAL PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD.
HAROLD: YEAH, INCREDIBLE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO, IN HER LITERARY AND
ORATORY WORK, SHE WARNS AGAINS
THE "DANGER OF A SINGLE
STORY"-THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE
LIVING IN CERTAIN PARTS OF THE
WORLD ALL HAVE ONE KIND OF
EXPERIENCE-AND SHE REMINDS US T
ALWAYS SEEK THE TRUTH.
AS A NIGERIAN-AMERICAN MYSELF,
CAN SAY WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT HE
WORK HAS INSPIRED
CROSS-GENERATIONAL COMMUNICATIO
ABOUT THE HISTORY AND TRAGEDIES
THAT HAVE SHAPED THE LIVED
EXPERIENCES OF MILLIONS. THROUGH
HER WRITING, SPEECHES, AND
ACTIVIST WORK, SHE BRINGS LIGHT
TO THE MANY SACRIFICES THAT
MEMBERS OF THE DIASPORA, LIKE MY
PARENTS, MAKE IN HOPE OF A
BRIGHTER FUTURE.
HER NARRATIVES OF LOVE, GRIT,
AND DIVERSITY GIVE A VOICE TO
THE VOICELESS, AND POWER TO
THOSE WHO HAVE OFTEN BEEN
OVERLOOKED BY HISTORY.
SHUYU: TODAY, WITH THE UTMOST
HONOR, WE INTRODUCE TO YOU OUR
2019 YALE CLASS DAY SPEAKER >>
MS. CHIMAMANDA NGOZI ADICHIE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
CHIMAMANDA ADICHIE: THANK YOU
FOR THAT WARM WELCOME.
I'M JUST FEELING THE LOVE.
CONGRATULATIONS, GRADUATES IN
THE CLASS OF 2019.
SO, LAST YEAR THE CLASS DAY
SPEAKER WAS HILLARY RODHAM
CLINTON.
THIS YEAR, YOU GOT ME.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
AND SO -- AND SO, I WANT TO
START BY TELLING YOU HOW SORRY I
AM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND BY THE WAY, CONSIDERING THE
LAST THREE YEARS, I IMAGINE YOU
MUST HAVE BEEN -- FOR LAST
YEAR'S CLASS TO HEAR FROM A
POLITICIAN WHO IS AN ACTUAL
ADULT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
TO HEAR FROM A PERSON WHO IS
ARTICULATE, EXPERIENCED,
THOUGHTFUL, LITERATE, MEASURED,
AND WITH AN ADULT'S VOCABULARY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
IT'S BEEN TEN YEARS SINCE I WAS
HERE IN GRADUATE SCHOOL.
I WASN'T ALWAYS HAPPY HERE.
FOR REASONS HAVING TO DO MORE
WITH ME THAN WITH YALE.
SO, IT WASN'T YALE, IT WAS ME.
BUT I WOULDN'T CHANGE ANY OF
IT.
IT'S GOOD TO BE BACK.
AND TO BE REMINDED OF SPENDING
HOURS IN THE BOOKSTORE AND
GETTING DINNER AT THE INDIAN
RESTAURANT THAT MY HUSBAND AND I
LOVED.
AND ATTENDING SEMINARS IN
PROFESSOR'S HOUSE WHICH WAS FULL
OF OBJECTS THAT HE COLLECTED IN
CENTRAL AFRICA IN THE 1960s.
AND THERE WAS ALSO THE SLIGHTLY
AWKWARD SEMINARY TOOK ON AFRICAN
LITERATURE IN WHICH MY OWN NOVEL
WAS PART OF THE CURRICULUM.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I JUST SAT THERE AND SAID
NOTHING.
AND I WASN'T SURE WHAT TO DO
WITH MY FACE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY, BEING HERE
AT YALE AFFORDED ME MANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENGAGE IN THAT
ACTIVITY THAT IS ESSENTIAL FOR A
FICTION WRITER: EAVESDROPPING.
I DID IT IN THE LIBRARY, IN THE
GYM.
BY WALKING A LITTLE TOO CLOSE TO
PEOPLE IN THE HALLWAYS.
AND FOR A WRITER, ALMOST NOTHING
IS OUT OF BOUNDS IF IT LEADS TO
COLLECTING MATERIAL FOR
FICTION.
AND YALE, HAVING SUCH A WIDE
RANGE OF INTERESTING PEOPLE, I
MEAN, JUST LOOK AT YOUR HATS.
THE MATERIAL I COLLECTED HERE
WAS ABSOLUTE GOLD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M VERY HONORED AND VERY HAPPY
TO BE YOUR CLASS DAY SPEAKER.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME.
I KNOW YOU'RE ALL EXCITED TO BE
GRADUATING.
AND WHILE I CONGRATULATE YOU, I
ALSO WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT IT
ONLY GOES DOWNHILL FROM HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WELL, NO, NOT REALLY, NOT
REALLY.
WHEN I GRADUATED FROM UNDERGRAD,
I FELT UNMOORED.
THE STRUCTURE OF EXPECTATIONS
WAS GONE.
NO MORE CLASSES TO ATTEND.
NO MORE PAPERS TO WRITE.
AND THE WORLD FELT WIDE OPEN,
DISORIENTING, DIZZYING.
I WAS FULL OF CONTRADICTIONS.
AND I WAS IN A BATTLE WITH
MYSELF ABOUT MY CONTRADICTIONS
BECAUSE I DID NOT KNOW THEN THAT
IT IS HUMAN AND OKAY TO HAVE
CONTRADICTIONS.
I WAS FULL OF UNCERTAINTY.
AND I DID NOT KNOW THAT
CONFIDENCE IS A JOURNEY.
A CONTINUOUS JOURNEY.
AND NOT AN ABSOLUTE
DESTINATION.
AND I WANT TO TELL YOU THIS NOW
TO SAVE YOU YEARS OF FIGURING IT
OUT YOURSELF.
THERE ARE DAYS WHEN YOU WILL BE
BURSTING WITH CERTAINTY.
AND DAYS WHEN YOU WILL BE
FLATTENED BY DOUBTS.
AND IT HELPS A LITTLE TO KEEP IN
MIND HOW UNIVERSAL THIS IS.
THERE'S SO MANY THINGS I SAID I
WOULD NEVER DO WHEN I WAS
YOUNGER.
AND I NOW DO MANY OF THEM.
I WOULD GIVE YOU DETAILED
EXAMPLES, BUT I DON'T WANT TO
UNNECESSARILY ALARM YOU.
THE POINT IS, BE OPEN TO
CHANGING YOUR MIND.
IT IS OFTEN A SIGN OF GROWTH.
BE OPEN TO THE POSSIBILITY THAT
YOU MIGHT BE WRONG.
IDEOLOGY IS A GOOD THING.
BUT IF YOU FIND THAT YOU HEW
UNQUESTIONINGLY TO EVERY
ORTHODOXY OF THE IDEOLOGY YOU
SUBSCRIBE TO, THEN MAYBE IT'S
TIME FOR SOME AGILITY IN YOUR
THINKING.
A SMALL SHIFT, FOR EXAMPLE.
A SIGN THAT SHOWS YOU KNOW THAT
THERE ARE COMPLICATED SHADES OF
GRAY EVERYWHERE.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU MARRY
BEING IDEALISTIC WITH BEING
PRAGMATIC.
AND IT HELPS TO THINK OF
PURITANISM AS TWO EXPENSIVE.
AS SOMETHING YOU CANNOT AFFORD.
SO, POLITICS IS AWFUL IN ALL
SORTS OF WAYS.
BUT REFUSING TO PARTICIPATE IS
NOT THE ANSWER.
SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO GET IN
THERE TO BE ABLE TO WALK TOWARDS
CHANGING IT TO WHAT YOU WANT IT
TO BE.
ENGAGE WITH THE WALL THAT'S AS
IT IS.
OTHERWISE YOU WON'T REALLY GET
ANYTHING DONE.
BUT AS YOU DO SO, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE AS YOUR
GUIDING LIGHT A CLEAR VISION OF
WHAT THE WORLD SHOULD BE.
I THINK OF MY WRITING AS MY
VOCATION.
IT IS WHAT I AM ON EARTH TO DO.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO KNOW ME
NOT FOR MY WRITING, BUT FOR MY
SPEAKING ABOUT FEMINISM.
I DID NOT SET OUT TO BE A
FEMINIST ICON.
AND I'M STILL HOPING THAT
SOMEBODY WILL MAKE ME A HAT THAT
SAYS "FEMINIST ICON."
I HAPPENED TO HAVE A PLATFORM
FROM MY WRITING AND I HAPPENED
TO FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT JUSTICE
IN GENERAL, WITH EQUALITY IN
WOMEN IN PARTICULAR, AND I BEGAN
TO USE THAT PLATFORM TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT MATTERED TO ME.
AND IT HAPPENED TO RESONATE WITH
PEOPLE WHO ALREADY WERE THINKING
ABOUT THE SAME THINGS.
IT ALSO HAPPENED TO IRRITATE
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE.
I REMEMBER A MAN WHO SPENT A LOT
OF TIME TRYING TO EXPLAIN TO ME
WHY HIS WIFE ALWAYS HAD TO
SUBMIT TO HIM.
I WAS A BIT CONFUSED ABOUT WHY
ANYBODY WOULD BE SO INSISTENT ON
THE IDEA THAT THE RIGHTFUL PLACE
FOR A FELLOW HUMAN BEING WAS A
PLACE OF PERMANENT SUBJUGATION.
WHY WOULD A WELL-BALANCED PERSON
NEED ANOTHER PERSON TO SUBMIT?
THE WORLD IS FULL OF PEOPLE LIKE
THAT MAN.
IS IT NECESSARILY MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO EDUCATE THEM?
NO.
DO I WANT TO?
YES.
WHY?
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S WORTHWHILE
TO GIVE PEOPLE, MOST PEOPLE, THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S WORTH
TRYING TO CHANGE A PERSON'S MIND
IF THAT WILL LEAD TO A GREATER
HUMAN GOOD.
AND BECAUSE, FULL DISCLOSURE, I
HAPPEN TO HAVE A MILD CASE OF
MESSIAH COMPLEX.
I WANT TO CHANGE A SMALL SLICE
OF THE WORLD.
SO, WILL TRYING TO GET A MAN TO
SEE THE FULL HUMANITY OF WOMEN
MEAN THAT HE MIGHT, FOR EXAMPLE,
STOP JUSTIFYING DOMESTIC ABUSE?
MAYBE.
MAYBE NOT.
BUT I WANT TO TRY.
I SEE IT AS TRYING TO WALK
TOWARDS MAKING A SMALL SLICE OF
THE KIND OF WORLD I WANT TO LIVE
IN.
I HAVE A DEAR FRIEND WHO LIVES
IN LAGOS.
HER NAME IS BOSSE, SHE'S AN
UTTERLY BRILLIANT GYNECOLOGIST
AND HAS A DAUGHTER WHO INHERED
HER MOTHER'S GENES.
SHE GREW UP IN NAYA AND WENT TO
THE UK FOR SCHOOL.
SHE EXCELLED AND WAS TOP OF THE
CLASS EVERY SUBJECT.
THEY WERE THINKING ABOUT WHERE
SHE WAS TO GO TO UNIVERSITY.
AND BECAUSE I DEEPLY ADMIRE THE
AMERICAN LIBERAL ARTS
CURRICULUM, I TOLD HER HOW I
THOUGHT SHE WOULD BENEFIT FROM
GOING TO UNIVERSITY IN THE U.S.
RATHER THAN THE UK.
HER RESPONSE, IN A VERY CALM,
16-YEAR-OLD VOICE WAS, I DON'T
WANT TO GO TO AMERICA BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO DIE.
THE STARKNESS, THE DIRECTNESS OF
HER WORDS THREW ME OFF FOR A
MOMENT.
OBVIOUSLY SHE MEANT GUNS.
HER MOTHER LATER TOLD ME THAT
SHE HAD BEEN PARTICULARLY SCARED
BY THE VIDEO OF A WHITE
POLICEMAN SHOOTING A BLACK MAN
IN THE BACK.
THERE IS A FIGURATIVE EXPRESSION
FOR A CERTAIN KIND OF A
DISRUPTION, A TROUBLEDNESS.
THAT EXPRESSION IS
EPHAPAMAPARO -- AND IT
TRANSLATES LITERALLY TO, THINGS
ARE NOT STANDING WELL.
THE AWKWARD BEAUTY OF THIS
EXPRESSION "THINGS ARE NOT
STANDING WELL," BEST CAPTURES MY
SENSE OF AMERICA TODAY.
TO SAY THAT THINGS ARE FALLING
APART, OR HAVE FALLEN APART
MIGHT SOUND AS THOUGH ONE IS
SUSCEPTIBLE TO ME ME LOW
DRAMATIC EXAGGERATION.
BUT THINGS ARE NOT STANDING
WELL.
WHEREVER YOU MIGHT BE ON THE
IDEOLOGICAL SPECTRUM, THINGS ARE
NOT STANDING WELL IF FEAR IS IN
THE AIR THAT AMERICANS BREATHE.
I BRING THIS UP BECAUSE I WANT
TO SUGGEST THAT AS YOU GRADUATE
IN THIS TIME, THAT YOU ASK
YOURSELF THE QUESTION, WHAT
SHOULD AMERICA BE?
SHOULD AMERICA BE A COUNTRY
WHERE FEAR IS ALWAYS AN OPTION
FOR CHILDREN IN SCHOOL?
WHERE A CHILD CAN GO TO SCHOOL
AND NEVER COME HOME BECAUSE THAT
CHILD HAS BEEN MURDERED BY
ANOTHER CHILD WITH A GUN?
SHOULD AMERICA BE A COUNTRY
WHERE BLACK PEOPLE LIVE IN FEAR
OF THEIR LIVES BECAUSE MEMBERS
OF THE POLICE DO NOT SEEM TO
THINK OF THEM AS FULL HUMAN
BEINGS?
SHOULD AMERICA BE A COUNTRY
WHERE WOMEN ARE IN FEAR OF NOT
HAVING FULL AUTONOMY OVER THEIR
BODIES?
IS A COUNTRY STILL A FULL
DEMOCRACY IF FEAR IS IN THE AIR
ITS CITIZENS BREATHE?
SHOULD AMERICA BE A COUNTRY OF
PATRIOTS?
PEOPLE INSPIRED BY LOVE AND
PRIDE.
OR SHOULD IT BE A COUNTRY OF
NATIONALISTS?
PEOPLE INSPIRED BY HATRED OF
ENEMIES.
MANY OF THOSE ENEMIES REAL, AND
MANY MORE INVENTED.
WHAT SHOULD AMERICA BE?
CONCEPTUALIZE THAT AMERICA AND
THEN MAKE THE CASE FOR THAT
AMERICA.
NOT ONLY IN OBVIOUS WAYS, SUCH
AS HOW YOU VOTE, BUT ALSO IN
SMALLER WAYS.
HOW YOU TREAT OTHER PEOPLE.
HOW YOU THINK OF OTHER PEOPLE.
THE THINGS YOU REFUSE TO
CONDONE.
THE PEOPLE WHOSE GRIEVANCES YOU
REFUSE TO DISMISS.
ACTS OF KINDNESS YOU DO.
THE PEOPLE YOU CHOOSE TO LISTEN
TO AND TO HEAR.
AND TRYING TO HEAR PEOPLE CAN
OFTEN BE THE BEST WAY OF SHOWING
THEM THAT THEY MATTER.
SO, GOING BY HISTORICAL
PRECEDENT, A YALE DEGREE MAKES
YOU MORE LIKELY THAN THE AVERAGE
GRADUATE TO BECOME PRESIDENT OR
A SENATOR.
OR A SUPREME COURT JUDGE.
A YALE DEGREE MAKES YOU MORE
LIKELY TO BECOME A PERSON WHO IN
DIFFERENT CAPACITIES WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR POLICIES AND
ACTIONS THAT WILL AFFECT THE
LIVES OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
NO QUESTION.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS PROOF, IF WE
EVER NEEDED PROOF, OF HOW FAIR
AMERICA'S UNIMPEACHABLE
MERITOCRACY IS.
NOT.
THE POINT IS, THOUGH, IS THAT A
YALE DEGREE WILL OPEN DOORS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WILL RESENT
YOU FOR HAVING A YALE DEGREE.
BUT THERE ARE MANY MORE PEOPLE
WHO WILL ACCORD YOU THE
AUTOMATIC ASSUMPTION OF
COMPETENCE.
IF YOUR DEGREE DOES END UP
PROPELLING YOU TO POWER,
REMEMBER THAT IF POWER WERE A
JACKET, IT IS MOST FLATTERING ON
ALL BODY TYPES WHEN WORN VERY
LIGHTLY.
IF YOU END UP WALKING IN A
NON-PROFIT, REMEMBER THAT THE
BEST CHARITY IS THAT WHICH DOES
NOT PERPETUATE ITSELF.
NEVER FORGET THAT HUMAN BEINGS,
ACTUAL HUMAN BEINGS WITH DREAMS
AND HOPES AND FEARS, WITH PRIDE
AND THINGS LIKE DISLIKE AND LIKE
ARE THE FORCE OF YOUR CHARITY.
NUMBERS, STATISTICS, LANGUAGE,
CAN SOMETIMES MAKE THE REAL
HUMANITY OF PEOPLE INVISIBLE.
AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE YOU EXPECT
TO BE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR CHARITY
WILL NOT BE.
AT LEAST NOT IN THE WAY YOU WANT
OR EXPECT.
BECAUSE IT CAN BE COMPLICATED TO
BE THE RECIPIENT OF CHARITY.
IF YOUR JOB INVOLVES TRAVELING
AROUND THE WORLD, REMEMBER THAT
LOCAL KNOWLEDGE IS ALWAYS BEST.
YES, READ THE COUNTRY REPORTS
WRITTEN BY THE CIA OR WHOEVER
WRITES THOSE REPORTS.
BUT PLACE A HIGHER VALUE ON
LOCAL KNOWLEDGE.
LOCAL NEWSPAPERS, LITERATURE,
THE PERSON WHO PICKS YOU UP FROM
THE AIRPORT.
AND IF YOU ARE ONE DAY ENROBED
IN CORPORATE POWER, AND SOME OF
YOU HERE CERTAINLY WILL BE,
PLEASE HIRE WOMEN AS EXECUTIVES
AND NOT JUST IN HUMAN RELATIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CHANGE THE CULTURE.
HAVE AN ON-SITE DAYCARE.
MAKE PAID FAMILY LEAVE STANDARD
AND ORDINARY.
IF YOU FIND YOURSELF WITH POWER
IN THE WORLD OF JOURNALISM,
BANISH FOREVER THE PRACTICE OF
FALSE EQUIVALENCE.
JOURNAL YOU FEEL SHOULD BE ABOUT
THE TRUTH, NOT ABOUT BALANCE.
IF YOU'RE REPORTING ON THE FACTS
THAT CLIMATE CHANGE EXISTS, YOU
DON'T NEED TO BRING IN A HACK TO
SHOW THE OTHER SIDE BECAUSE
THERE IS NO OTHER SIDE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND IF YOU DO BECOME A
JOURNALIST, PLEASE LEARN HOW TO
SAY, "I'M SORRY.  "
JOURNALISM SEEMS TO BE A
PROFESSION WHOSE PRACTITIONERS
HAVE GREAT DIFFICULTY IN SAYING
I'M SORRY WITHOUT HEDGING OR
EQUIVOCATING.
AND SPEAKING OF SAYING SORRY,
KNOWING HOW TO SAY I'M SORRY AND
MEAN I'M SORRY WILL SERVE YOU
WELL NO MATTER WHAT COURSE YOUR
LIFE TAKES.
AND IF YOU ARE ONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE WHO SEEMS UNABLE TO FORM
THOSE WORDS I'M SORRY, THERE IS
HOPE.
PRACTICING IN FRONT OF A MIRROR
HELPS.
DON'T CHANGE THE SUBJECT.
DON'T PRETEND THAT NOTHING
HAPPENED.
DON'T BUY A GIFT AND DEFLECT.
DON'T RIDE IT OUT IN SILENCE
HOPING IT WILL GO AWAY.
JUST SAY I'M SORRY.
A FEW TIMES, IF NECESSARY.
AND, OF COURSE, IT HELPS IF YOU
ACTUALLY NEED IT.
BUT PLEASE DO NOT EVER APOLOGIZE
FOR EXISTING.
OR FOR TAKING UP SPACE IN THE
WORLD.
OR FOR HAVING A WELL-CONSIDERED
OPINION.
AND I SAY THIS PARTICULARLY TO
WOMEN WHOSE SOCIALIZATION
TEACHES THEM, TEACHES US, TO
SHRINK OURSELVES.
AS THOUGH OUR RESPONSIBILITY IS
NEVER FIRST TO OURSELVES.
BUT ALWAYS TO OTHERS.
AND WE END UP SOMETIMES FEELING
GUILTY FOR WANTING THE THINGS WE
WANT.
FOR WANTING TO BE OUR OWN SELVES
FIRST.
THE MESSAGES THAT SOCIETY SENDS
US CAN BE COMPLICATE --
CONFLICTING.
THAT TENSION BETWEEN TELLING YOU
TO VALUE YOURSELF, THAT YOU
MATTER, AND THEN THAT OTHER
MESSAGE THAT TELLS YOU TO PUT
OTHER PEOPLE FIRST AND TO
SERVE.
IT IS POSSIBLE -- IT IS
NECESSARY -- THAT YOU FIND A
BALANCE BETWEEN THE TWO.
BUT YOU WILL HAVE TO FIGURE IT
OUT YOURSELF.
BUT IF I CAN OFFER A USEFUL
GUIDING PRINCIPLE, IT IS THIS:
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO MAKE ROOM IN
YOUR LIFE FOR PEOPLE WHO WISH
YOU HARM.
SO, ONE ENDURING LESSON I
LEARNED HERE AT YALE IS ALWAYS
TO LOOK AT PRIMARY SOURCES
FIRST.
AND I'VE HELD ON TO THAT
LESSON.
IT IS, I THINK, A USEFUL LESSON
IN EXPRESSION IN THIS AGE OF
EASY OUTRAGE.
WHEN SO MANY PEOPLE ARE QUICK TO
REACT TO AN ISOLATED QUOTE OR
SOMETIMES RECEIVED SECOND OR
THIRD HAND.
SO, I ONCE READ A BOOK REVIEW.
AND BASED ON THAT REVIEW I
DECIDED NOT TO READ THE BOOK
BECAUSE IT DIDN'T SOUND LIKE MY
SORT OF THING.
LATER, I READ THE BOOK BECAUSE I
WAS ALTHOUGH A WRITING RETREAT
AND IT WAS SITTING THERE AT A
SHELF AND I THOUGHT I WOULD JUST
READ ONE PAGE AND THEN I
COULDN'T STOP.
I LOVED IT.
AND I COULD NOT BELIEVE HOW THAT
REVIEWER COULD HAVE SO
MISCHARACTERIZED THAT BOOK.
SO, IF YOU CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE CONSULT OF THE OUTRAGE OF
THE DAY ON SOCIAL MEDIA, AND IF
YOU'RE QUICK TO JUMP IN WITH
YOUR BLISTERING TAKE -- AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE ADRENALINE
BOOST CAN BE ADDICTIVE -- BUT
BEFORE YOU JUMP IN THE FRAY,
LOOK UP PRIMARY SOURCES FIRST.
AND REMEMBER THAT CONTEXT IS
ALWAYS QUEEN.
THIS IS ALSO, I THINK, A GOOD
WAY OF TESTING YOUR OWN
BELIEFS.
TAKE A LITTLE TIME TO FIND OUT
WHAT WAS ACTUALLY SAID OR DONE.
AND IF YOU HAVE CONTEXT, THEN
MAYBE -- MAYBE -- YOU MIGHT JUST
START TO QUESTION WHAT YOU
THOUGHT YOU KNEW.
HAVING SAID THAT, I DO SOMETIMES
WORRY THAT AMERICAN EDUCATION
HAS CREATED A CLASS OF
BRILLIANT, TALENTED PEOPLE.
BUT PEOPLE WHO ARE, NONETHELESS,
AFRAID TO SAY THE WRONG THING.
EVEN IN OSTENSIBLY SAFE SPACES.
IF THE WORLD INSIDE OF COLLEGE
WAS SAFE, THEN YOU SHOULD KNOW
THAT THE WORLD OUTSIDE OF
COLLEGE IS NOT.
AND I URGE YOU, ALWAYS, ALWAYS,
TO HONOR THE DOUBTS THAT YOU
HAVE.
HONOR THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU
DON'T SILENCE YOURSELF.
HAVE.
SO, I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT A
DON'T SILENCE YOURSELF.
CONVERSATION THAT HAPPENED AMONG
SO, I WANT TO TELL YOU ABOUT A
A GROUP OF PEOPLE RECENTLY.
CONVERSATION THAT HAPPENED AMONG
PEOPLE WHO WERE ACQUAINTANCES,
A GROUP OF PEOPLE RECENTLY.
IF NOT FRIENDS.
PEOPLE WHO WERE ACQUAINTANCES,
BUT WHO ALL GENERALLY WERE ON
IF NOT FRIENDS.
THE SAME SIDE.
BUT WHO ALL GENERALLY WERE ON
AND I MIGHT OR MIGHT NOT HAVE
THE SAME SIDE.
BEEN EVESDROPPING ON THEIR
AND I MIGHT OR MIGHT NOT HAVE
CONVERSATION.
BEEN EVESDROPPING ON THEIR
SO, THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT A
CONVERSATION.
POLITICIAN AND ONE OF THEM SAID
SO, THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT A
THAT THE POLITICIAN WAS A RACIST
POLITICIAN AND ONE OF THEM SAID
BECAUSE THAT POLITICIAN
THAT THE POLITICIAN WAS A RACIST
SUPPORTED SCHOOL CHOICE.
BECAUSE THAT POLITICIAN
AT ONE THEN ASKED, TENTATIVELY,
SUPPORTED SCHOOL CHOICE.
BUT HOW?
AT ONE THEN ASKED, TENTATIVELY,
AND THE RESPONSE FROM EVERYONE
BUT HOW?
ELSE IN THIS GROUP WAS A LOT OF
AND THE RESPONSE FROM EVERYONE
EYE ROLLING.
ELSE IN THIS GROUP WAS A LOT OF
A LOT OF SNEERING.
EYE ROLLING.
AND THEN, FINALLY, ONE PERSON
A LOT OF SNEERING.
GAVE A TREATISE ON HOW
AND THEN, FINALLY, ONE PERSON
SUPPORTING THIS POLITICIAN WAS
GAVE A TREATISE ON HOW
SUPPORTING RACISM.
SUPPORTING THIS POLITICIAN WAS
AND NOBODY TOLD WHY SUPPORTING
SUPPORTING RACISM.
SCHOOL CHOICE WAS INCORRECT.
AND NOBODY TOLD WHY SUPPORTING
AND THERE'S A VALID ARGUMENT,
SCHOOL CHOICE WAS INCORRECT.
AND THEY WERE LEFT NOT KNOWING
AND THERE'S A VALID ARGUMENT,
THE ARGUMENT AND PERHAPS LEFT
AND THEY WERE LEFT NOT KNOWING
FEELING HEAVIER WITH SEVERAL
THE ARGUMENT AND PERHAPS LEFT
LAYERS OF SHAME.  I WORRY THAT
FEELING HEAVIER WITH SEVERAL
THE SPACES OCCUPIED BY THE
LAYERS OF SHAME.  I WORRY THAT
EDUCATED IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE
THE SPACES OCCUPIED BY THE
BECOME PLACES WHERE CURIOSITY IS
EDUCATED IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE
CONSIDERED PASSE.
BECOME PLACES WHERE CURIOSITY IS
IT IS NOW AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
CONSIDERED PASSE.
EVERYONE IS ALREADY SUPPOSED TO
IT IS NOW AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
KNOW, SUPPOSED TO GET IT.
EVERYONE IS ALREADY SUPPOSED TO
AND THOSE WHO DON'T ARE SEEN AS
KNOW, SUPPOSED TO GET IT.
MORALLY LACKING.
AND THOSE WHO DON'T ARE SEEN AS
IF THERE IS A LESSON HERE, IT IS
MORALLY LACKING.
THAT YOU SHOULD ALWAYS REMEMBER
IF THERE IS A LESSON HERE, IT IS
THAT A SELF-RIGHTEOUS SNEER IS
THAT YOU SHOULD ALWAYS REMEMBER
NOT AN ARGUMENT.
THAT A SELF-RIGHTEOUS SNEER IS
DON'T BE THAT PERSON WHO ATTACKS
NOT AN ARGUMENT.
OR DEMEANS BECAUSE YOU ARE
DON'T BE THAT PERSON WHO ATTACKS
UNABLE TO CONVINCE.
OR DEMEANS BECAUSE YOU ARE
I KNOW THAT THE IDEA OF BRINGING
UNABLE TO CONVINCE.
RECEIPTS IS A THING IN YOUR
I KNOW THAT THE IDEA OF BRINGING
GENERATION.
RECEIPTS IS A THING IN YOUR
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE IF
GENERATION.
SOMEONE IN THAT GROUP HAD
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN NICE IF
BROUGHT RECEIPTS.
SOMEONE IN THAT GROUP HAD
MAKE THE ARGUMENT, CLARIFY,
BROUGHT RECEIPTS.
EXPLAIN, DO THE WORK, CITE
MAKE THE ARGUMENT, CLARIFY,
STATISTICS IF YOU NEED TO.
EXPLAIN, DO THE WORK, CITE
AND BRING THE DARNED RECEIPTS.
STATISTICS IF YOU NEED TO.
WHEN I STARTED OUT WRITING, I
AND BRING THE DARNED RECEIPTS.
WAS DOING WHAT I LOVED.
WHEN I STARTED OUT WRITING, I
WHAT GAVE ME THE GREATEST JOY.
WAS DOING WHAT I LOVED.
AND I HOPED ALSO TO BE READ.
WHAT GAVE ME THE GREATEST JOY.
AND TODAY I FEEL GRATEFUL TO BE
AND I HOPED ALSO TO BE READ.
READ, TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
AND TODAY I FEEL GRATEFUL TO BE
TO BE HERE.
READ, TO BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
MY WORK IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
TO BE HERE.
ME.
MY WORK IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
IT'S CENTRAL TO MY LIFE.
ME.
BUT THE MOMENT OF GREATEST JOY
IT'S CENTRAL TO MY LIFE.
FOR ME ARE NOT NECESSARILY THOSE
BUT THE MOMENT OF GREATEST JOY
THAT HAVE TO DO WITH MY
FOR ME ARE NOT NECESSARILY THOSE
SUCCESS.
THAT HAVE TO DO WITH MY
AND SO, PLEASE NURTURE YOUR
SUCCESS.
AMBITIONS.
AND SO, PLEASE NURTURE YOUR
SEEK TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
AMBITIONS.
BUT KEEP IN MIND THAT THERE ARE
SEEK TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
HOLLOWS THAT SUCCESS WILL NOT
BUT KEEP IN MIND THAT THERE ARE
FEEL.
HOLLOWS THAT SUCCESS WILL NOT
AND, YES, THIS IS WHERE I TALK
FEEL.
ABOUT LOVE.
AND, YES, THIS IS WHERE I TALK
I HAVE A SWISS FRIEND WHO ONCE
ABOUT LOVE.
LIVED IN D.C. BUT NOW LIVES IN
I HAVE A SWISS FRIEND WHO ONCE
ZURICH.
LIVED IN D.C. BUT NOW LIVES IN
AND I ASKED HIM WHAT HE HAD MADE
ZURICH.
OF AMERICA WHEN HE LIVED HERE.
AND I ASKED HIM WHAT HE HAD MADE
AND HE SAID, AMERICANS DON'T
OF AMERICA WHEN HE LIVED HERE.
HAVE FRIENDS BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO
AND HE SAID, AMERICANS DON'T
BUSY WORKING.
HAVE FRIENDS BECAUSE THEY'RE TOO
HE MEANT, I THINK, PEOPLE WHO
BUSY WORKING.
LIVE IN AMERICA.
HE MEANT, I THINK, PEOPLE WHO
WHETHER CITIZENS OR NOT.
LIVE IN AMERICA.
AND SO, I URGE YOU, CLASS OF
WHETHER CITIZENS OR NOT.
2019, TO PROVE HIM WRONG.
AND SO, I URGE YOU, CLASS OF
HAVE FRIENDS.
2019, TO PROVE HIM WRONG.
MANY FRIENDS.
HAVE FRIENDS.
OR JUST ONE FRIEND.
MANY FRIENDS.
HOLD YOUR FAMILY CLOSE.
OR JUST ONE FRIEND.
AND FAMILY DOESN'T NECESSARILY
HOLD YOUR FAMILY CLOSE.
MEAN THOSE WITH WHOM YOU'RE
AND FAMILY DOESN'T NECESSARILY
RELATED BY BLOOD OR BY
MEAN THOSE WITH WHOM YOU'RE
INSTITUTION.
RELATED BY BLOOD OR BY
HOLD YOUR FRIENDS CLOSE.
INSTITUTION.
STAND UP FOR YOUR LOVED ONES.
HOLD YOUR FRIENDS CLOSE.
TELL THE PEOPLE YOU LOVE THAT
STAND UP FOR YOUR LOVED ONES.
YOU LOVE THEM.
TELL THE PEOPLE YOU LOVE THAT
TELL THEM OFTEN.
YOU LOVE THEM.
FIND REASONS TO LAUGH.
TELL THEM OFTEN.
GRAVITATE TOWARDS PEOPLE WITH
FIND REASONS TO LAUGH.
WHOM YOU NEVER FEEL THAT
GRAVITATE TOWARDS PEOPLE WITH
PRESSURE TO PERFORM OR TO BE
WHOM YOU NEVER FEEL THAT
WHAT YOU'RE NOT.
PRESSURE TO PERFORM OR TO BE
ONE OF THE TENANTS I TRY TO LIVE
WHAT YOU'RE NOT.
BY IS NEVER ADMIRE QUIETLY.
ONE OF THE TENANTS I TRY TO LIVE
IF I ADMIRE SOMETHING ABOUT
BY IS NEVER ADMIRE QUIETLY.
SOMEONE, I LET THEM KNOW.
IF I ADMIRE SOMETHING ABOUT
WE DO NOT ALWAYS RECOGNIZE WHAT
SOMEONE, I LET THEM KNOW.
IS BEAUTIFUL IN OURSELVES, IN
WE DO NOT ALWAYS RECOGNIZE WHAT
OUR SPIRITS, UNTIL SOMEBODY HAS
IS BEAUTIFUL IN OURSELVES, IN
POINTED IT OUT TO US.
OUR SPIRITS, UNTIL SOMEBODY HAS
AND REMEMBER THAT PEOPLE WILL
POINTED IT OUT TO US.
HARDLY EVER FORGET SMALL ACTS OF
AND REMEMBER THAT PEOPLE WILL
KINDNESS.
HARDLY EVER FORGET SMALL ACTS OF
I REMEMBER ONCE DURING A PUBLIC
KINDNESS.
EVENT I WAS A LITTLE EXHAUSTED.
I REMEMBER ONCE DURING A PUBLIC
I WAS A LITTLE GRUMPY.
EVENT I WAS A LITTLE EXHAUSTED.
ACTUALLY, I WAS VERY GRUMPY.
I WAS A LITTLE GRUMPY.
AND I WAS SURROUNDED BY PEOPLE.
ACTUALLY, I WAS VERY GRUMPY.
NONE OF WHOM SEEMED TO SEE MY
AND I WAS SURROUNDED BY PEOPLE.
EXHAUSTION.
NONE OF WHOM SEEMED TO SEE MY
AND THEN MY FRIEND WAS THERE,
EXHAUSTION.
SORT OF LOOKED AT ME AND SAID,
AND THEN MY FRIEND WAS THERE,
SHE'S TIRED.
SORT OF LOOKED AT ME AND SAID,
AND I ALMOST BURST INTO TEARS.
SHE'S TIRED.
BECAUSE I FELT SO WONDERFULLY
AND I ALMOST BURST INTO TEARS.
SEEN.
BECAUSE I FELT SO WONDERFULLY
BE KIND.
SEEN.
PAYING ATTENTION IS ONE OF THE
BE KIND.
MOST BEAUTIFUL ACTS OF
PAYING ATTENTION IS ONE OF THE
KINDNESS.
MOST BEAUTIFUL ACTS OF
THE PEOPLE YOU WILL COME ACROSS
KINDNESS.
IN YOUR LIFE WILL NOT FORGET
THE PEOPLE YOU WILL COME ACROSS
WHEN YOU ARE KIND.
IN YOUR LIFE WILL NOT FORGET
AND THEY WILL NOT FORGET WHEN
WHEN YOU ARE KIND.
YOU'RE UNKIND.
AND THEY WILL NOT FORGET WHEN
I WISH YOU WELL AS YOU GO OUT
YOU'RE UNKIND.
INTO THE WORLD.
I WISH YOU WELL AS YOU GO OUT
I WISH YOU COURAGE.
INTO THE WORLD.
I WISH YOU JOY.
I WISH YOU COURAGE.
AND ON A FINAL NOTE, AS YOU
I WISH YOU JOY.
NAVIGATE THE WORLD, IT MIGHT BE
AND ON A FINAL NOTE, AS YOU
HELPFUL FROM TIME TO TIME TO
NAVIGATE THE WORLD, IT MIGHT BE
FORGET THAT YOU WENT TO YALE.
HELPFUL FROM TIME TO TIME TO
CONGRATULATIONS.
FORGET THAT YOU WENT TO YALE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DR. MARVIN CHUN: ON BEHALF OF
YALE COLLEGE, I WANTED TO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR BEING THE PRIMARY
SOURCE OF YOUR WISDOM, INTELLECT
AND INSPIRATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR MESSIAH
SPIRIT.
YOU ARE READ, YOU ARE HEARD, YOU
ARE SEEN, YOU ARE LOVED.
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
OKAY.
SO, WE HAVE A LITTLE EXERCISE TO
DO HERE WITH ALL THE SENIORS.
BUT FIRST, I WANT TO ASK THE
FOLLOWING STUDENTS TO COME UP TO
THE SEATS OVER HERE IN THE FRONT
ROW RIGHT IN THE BAKING SUN.
SO, PLEASE COME UP WHEN I CALL
YOUR NAME.
JUDE ALRAHMAN ALAWA OF BRANFOR.
[ APPLAUSE ]
HANNAH LOUISE LAWRENCE OF
DAVENPORT COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ANDREA MASTERSON OF JONATHAN
EDWARDS COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LILY MIRFAKHRAIE OF DAVENPORT
COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
EREN ORBEY OF JONATHAN EDWARDS
COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
A.K. PAYNE OF BERKELEY COLLEGE.
ALANNA PYKE OF TIMOTHY DWIGHT
[ APPLAUSE ]
COLLEGE.
ALANNA PYKE OF TIMOTHY DWIGHT
[ APPLAUSE ]
COLLEGE.
DEVYN CHRISTINE RIGSBY OF
[ APPLAUSE ]
PIERSON COLLEGE.
DEVYN CHRISTINE RIGSBY OF
[ APPLAUSE ]
PIERSON COLLEGE.
SIMON WHITEMAN OF TRUMBULL
[ APPLAUSE ]
COLLEGE.
SIMON WHITEMAN OF TRUMBULL
[ APPLAUSE ]
COLLEGE.
ALL RIGHT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO, SENIORS, WE'RE GOING TO DO A
ALL RIGHT.
LITTLE DRESS REHEARSAL FOR
SO, SENIORS, WE'RE GOING TO DO A
TOMORROW.
LITTLE DRESS REHEARSAL FOR
THE MAIN COMMENCEMENT EVENT
TOMORROW.
HERE.
THE MAIN COMMENCEMENT EVENT
I'LL BE UP ON THE STAGE WHERE
HERE.
I'LL -- I'LL BE KIND OF STANDING
I'LL BE UP ON THE STAGE WHERE
RIGHT THERE FACING PRESIDENT
I'LL -- I'LL BE KIND OF STANDING
SALOVEY AND I WILL BE PRESENTING
RIGHT THERE FACING PRESIDENT
YOU ALL TO HIM SO THAT YOU CAN
SALOVEY AND I WILL BE PRESENTING
RECEIVE YOUR DEGREES.
YOU ALL TO HIM SO THAT YOU CAN
I'LL BE SAYING A FEW WORDS.
RECEIVE YOUR DEGREES.
THE LAST TWO SENTENCES OF MY
I'LL BE SAYING A FEW WORDS.
REQUEST ARE GOING TO BE LIKE
THE LAST TWO SENTENCES OF MY
THIS:
REQUEST ARE GOING TO BE LIKE
"THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
THIS:
THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
"THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION. I
THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION. I
ACT, TO CONFER UP THEM THESE
NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES.
ACT, TO CONFER UP THEM THESE
".  SO, WHEN YOU HEAR
DEGREES.
THESE WORDS" CONFER UPON THEM
".  SO, WHEN YOU HEAR
THESE DEGREES" -- THAT'S WHEN
THESE WORDS" CONFER UPON THEM
YOU WANT TO SHOW THE WORLD HOW
THESE DEGREES" -- THAT'S WHEN
EXCITED YOU ARE TO BE
YOU WANT TO SHOW THE WORLD HOW
GRADUATING.
EXCITED YOU ARE TO BE
OKAY?
GRADUATING.
SO, YOU JUST DO YOUR THING.
OKAY?
SHOUT OUT AS LOUD AS YOU CAN.
SO, YOU JUST DO YOUR THING.
WE'RE GOING TO PRACTICE.
SHOUT OUT AS LOUD AS YOU CAN.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE WITH ALL
WE'RE GOING TO PRACTICE.
THE PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS,
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE WITH ALL
FAMILIES, ON TV AND EVERYTHING
THE PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS,
LIKE THAT.
FAMILIES, ON TV AND EVERYTHING
SO, LET'S HAVE A GOOD PRACTICE
LIKE THAT.
HERE.
SO, LET'S HAVE A GOOD PRACTICE
AND, AGAIN, AT THE END OF THESE
HERE.
DEGREES --
AND, AGAIN, AT THE END OF THESE
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
DEGREES --
THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
I NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES.
ACT, TO CONFER UPON THEM THESE
WE'LL TRY AGAIN.
DEGREES.
I MEAN, LIKE, THESE OTHER
WE'LL TRY AGAIN.
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS, THEY GOT
I MEAN, LIKE, THESE OTHER
CONFETTI GOING.
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS, THEY GOT
THEY'RE JUST A LOT MORE
CONFETTI GOING.
BOISTEROUS.
THEY'RE JUST A LOT MORE
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TRY THIS
BOISTEROUS.
AGAIN.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TRY THIS
ONE LAST TIME.
AGAIN.
AGAIN, I'M FACING PRESIDENT
ONE LAST TIME.
SALOVEY.
AGAIN, I'M FACING PRESIDENT
"THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
SALOVEY.
THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
"THEY HAVE BEEN RECOMMENDED BY
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION. I
THE FACULTY OF YALE COLLEGE AND
NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
APPROVED BY THE CORPORATION. I
ACT, TO CONFER UP THEM THESE
NOW ASK YOU, BY YOUR OFFICIAL
DEGREES".
ACT, TO CONFER UP THEM THESE
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
DEGREES".
OKAY.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
THAT'S MUCH BETTER.
OKAY.
STANDING UP, ALL THAT, WAVE YOUR
THAT'S MUCH BETTER.
FLAGS.
STANDING UP, ALL THAT, WAVE YOUR
WE LOOK FORWARD TO IT TOMORROW.
FLAGS.
GREAT.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO IT TOMORROW.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GREAT.
VICTORIA CHUN: THANK YOU,
[ LAUGHTER ]
BROTHER CHUN.
VICTORIA CHUN: THANK YOU,
WILL VARSITY THREATS ANDREA
BROTHER CHUN.
MASTERSON, SIMON WHITEMAN,
WILL VARSITY THREATS ANDREA
CAPTAINS OF THE CROSS COUNTRY
MASTERSON, SIMON WHITEMAN,
AND BASEBALL TEAMS, PLEASE COME
CAPTAINS OF THE CROSS COUNTRY
TO THE PODIUM?
AND BASEBALL TEAMS, PLEASE COME
[ APPLAUSE ]
ANDREA, YOU WILL GO DOWN IN THE
BOOKS AS ONE OF THE ALL-TIME
GREATS IN YALE WOMEN'S CROSS
COUNTRY.
YOU ARE THE IVY LEAGUE
HEPTAGONAL CROSS-COUNTRY
INDIVIDUAL CHAMPION FOR 2018, A
THREE-TIME NCAA QUALIFIER, A
TWO-TIME NCAA ALL-REGION HONORS
RECIPIENT AND A TWO-TIME HYP
CROSS COUNTRY INDIVIDUAL
CHAMPION.
IN TRACK AND FIELD, YOU HAVE
WRITTEN YOUR WAY ONTO THE
ALL-TIME LISTS IN FOUR EVENTS.
ANDREA, YOU HAVE ACCOMPLISHED
ALL OF THIS IN YOUR SPORT AT TH
SAME TIME YOU WERE MAJORING IN
ARCHITECTURE - AS LEGEND HAS IT
ONE OF THE MOST TIME-CONSUMING
MAJORS AT YALE!
IT TAKES A SPECIAL PERSON TO DO
THAT.
WE WISH YOU LUCK ON THURSDAY A
YOU WILL RACE AT THE NCAA FIRST
ROUNDS IN JACKSONVILLE, FLORIDA
TO QUALIFY FOR THE NCAA FINALS.
FOR YOUR SUPERB ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AS AN ATHLETE, YOUR SUCCESS IN
THE CLASSROOM AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND FOR EXEMPLIFYING
IN YOURSELF THE COMMITMENT, THE
HARD WORK AND EXCELLENCE OF SO
MANY VARSITY ATHLETES AT YALE,
YALE TAKES GREAT PRIDE IN
PRESENTING YOU ONE OF THE MOST
DISTINGUISHED RUNNERS IN YALE
WOMEN'S CROSS-COUNTRY HISTORY
WITH THE NELLIE P. ELLIOTT
AWARD.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SIMON, YOU, AS WELL, HAVE BEEN
THE CAPTAIN OF YOUR TEAM, A
LEADER TO WHOM OTHERS, AND I,
LOOK. IN COMING TO YALE, YOU
MOVED FROM SECOND BASE TO
SHORTSTOP, AND WITH VERY HARD
WORK, BECAME WHAT YOUR HEAD
COACH SAYS, IS THE BEST
SHORTSTOP HE HAS EVER HAD IN 27
YEARS AT YALE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEFENSIVELY, YOUR PLAY AT
SHORTSTOP HELPED YALE LEAD ALL
OF DIVISION I BASEBALL IN DOUBL
PLAYS PER GAME IN 2019 AND THE
2018 TEAM SET AN ALL-TIME
DIVISION I RECORD FOR FIELDING
PERCENTAGE.
AS A HITTER, YOU WERE AT THE T
OF THE BASEBALL LINEUP;
INCREDIBLY, YOU GRADUATE WITH
THE SECOND MOST HITS - 213 - AN
STOLEN BASES - 71 - IN THE
ENTIRE 154 YEARS OF YALE
BASEBALL HISTORY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
THIS AND YOUR TEAMMATES' EFFOR
LED TO TWO IVY LEAGUE
CHAMPIONSHIPS.
SPORTS MEDIA OUTLETS PREDICTS
YOU TO BE A PROFESSIONAL
BASEBALL PLAYER AND DRAFTED THIS
JUNE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SIMON, YOU HAVE DONE ALL OF TH
WHILE - GUESS WHAT? WINNING THE
DELANEY KIPUTH AWARD FOR THE
HIGHEST GRADE POINT AVERAGE OF
ANY GRADUATING SENIOR VARSITY
STUDENT-ATHLETE WITH A 3.97 GPA
IN CHEMICAL ENGINEERING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
YOUR LOWEST GRADE IN SEVEN
SEMESTERS WAS AN A- IN FRESHMAN
LAB.
I BET THAT PROFESSOR FEELS BAD.
IN YOUR JUNIOR YEAR YOU WERE T
CO-RECIPIENT OF ONE OF YALE'S
MOST PRESTIGIOUS PRIZES FOR AN
UNDERGRADUATE, THE FRANCIS
GORDON BROWN PRIZE, AN AWARD
ALSO WON BY A FORMER YALE
BASEBALL GREAT, U.S. PRESIDENT
GEORGE HW. BUSH.
FOR YOUR INCREDIBLE PERFORMANC
ON THE FIELD AND IN THE
CLASSROOM - ALWAYS WEARING A TI
TO CLASS - AND FOR KNOCKING IT
OUT OF THE PARK IN BOTH AREAS,
YALE TAKES ENORMOUS PRIDE IN
AWARDING YOU THE WILLIAM NEELY
MALLORY AWARD FOR 2019. [
APPLAUSE ]
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE BOTH OF
YOU AND TO THE SENIOR CLASS OF
2019!
[ APPLAUSE ]
JULIA ADAMS: ALANNA PYKE, WILL
YOU PLEASE COME UP TO THE STAGE?
[ APPLAUSE ]
AND JONATHAN SALAZAR, WILL YOU
PLEASE JOIN ALANNA?
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE NAKANISHI PRIZE IS AWARDED
TO TWO GRADUATING SENIORS WHO,
WHILE MAINTAINING HIGH ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT, HAVE PROVIDED
EXEMPLARY LEADERSHIP IN
ENHANCING RACE OR ETHNIC
RELATIONS AT YALE COLLEGE. THIS
YEAR'S PRIZES ARE AWARDED TO
ALANNA PYKE OF TIMOTHY DWIGHT
COLLEGE AND JONATHAN SALAZAR OF
PAULI MURRAY COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ALANNA PYKE, A MOLECULAR,
CELLULAR, AND DEVELOPMENTAL
BIOLOGY MAJOR HAILING FROM THE
MOHAWK NATION AT AKWESASNE, HAS
BEEN DESCRIBED AS A "FEARLESS
LEADER" OF THE NATIVE COMMUNITY
KNOWN FOR HER "GRACE, DIGNITY,
AND STRENGTH."
SHE HAS SERVED AS TD'S BIG SIB
COORDINATOR; AS A MEMBER OF THE
STUDENT ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO
THE CENTER FOR THE STUDY OF
RACE, INDIGENEITY, AND
TRANSNATIONAL MIGRATION; AND AS
A PEER LIAISON FOR THE NATIVE
AMERICAN CULTURAL CENTER
COMMUNITY.
AS PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDEN
FOR THE ASSOCIATION OF NATIVE
AMERICANS AT YALE, SHE HAS
DEVOTED HERSELF TO SUPPORTING
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE'S DAY
CELEBRATIONS AND THE IVY NATIVE
CONFERENCE ON INDIGENOUS
FEMINISMS, RE-ESTABLISHING THE
ANAAY POWWOW, AND ADVOCATING FO
WATER PROTECTORS AT STANDING
ROCK.
NEXT YEAR SHE WILL BE SERVING
A RESEARCH SCHOLAR IN THE
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF ARTS &
SCIENCES AT HARVARD AS SHE
PREPARES TO APPLY TO DOCTORAL
PROGRAMS.
FOR HER REMARKABLE SERVICE AND
LEADERSHIP, YALE COLLEGE IS
HONORED TO AWARD THE NAKANISHI
PRIZE TO ALANNA PYKE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
JONATHAN SALAZAR, AN ETHNICITY
RACE & MIGRATION MAJOR, HAS BEE
DESCRIBED AS A LEADER, A FRIEND
AND A SCHOLAR. ARRIVING AT YALE
AS A SECOND-YEAR STUDENT, WITH
AN ACUTE UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
IT WAS LIKE TO BE "NEW" AT YALE
AND SEEKING CONNECTION, JONATHA
HAS HAD AN OUTSIZED IMPACT IN
THE MANY ROLES HE HAS PLAYED. H
HAS SERVED AS A PEER LIAISON FO
LA CASA CULTURAL, AS A MEMBER O
BALLET FOLKLORICO, MECHA, AND L
CASA'S SENIOR EVENTS COMMITTEE,
AND AS ONE OF THE INAUGURAL
FIRST-GENERATION LOW INCOME
STUDENT AMBASSADORS.
THIS YEAR, HE SERVED AS HEAD
FIRST-YEAR COUNSELOR FOR PAULI
MURRAY COLLEGE.
IN ALL THESE ROLES, HE HAS
DEDICATED HIMSELF TO MAKING
EVERYONE FEEL WELCOME, CONNECTED
AND INCLUDED.
FOLLOWING GRADUATION, JONATHAN
WILL BE RETURNING TO NEW MEXICO
TO BEGIN WORK AS A PARALEGAL
WHILE PREPARING FOR GRADUATE
SCHOOL.
FOR HIS EXTRAORDINARY SERVICE
AND LEADERSHIP, YALE COLLEGE IS
HONORED TO AWARD THE NAKANISHI
PRIZE TO JONATHAN SALAZAR.
[ APPLAUSE ]
JUDE ALAWA, WILL YOU PLEASE CO
UP TO THE STAGE?
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE JAMES ANDREW HAAS PRIZE IS
AWARDED ANNUALLY TO "THAT MEMBE
OF THE SENIOR CLASS IN YALE
COLLEGE WHOSE BREADTH OF
INTELLECTUAL ACHIEVEMENT,
STRENGTH OF CHARACTER, AND
FUNDAMENTAL HUMANITY SHALL BE
ADJUDGED BY THE FACULTY TO HAVE
PROVIDED LEADERSHIP FOR HIS OR
HER FELLOW STUDENTS, INSPIRING
IN THEM A LOVE OF LEARNING AND
CONCERN FOR OTHERS."
THIS YEAR THE HAAS PRIZE IS
AWARDED TO JUDE ALRAHMAN ALAWA
OF BRANFORD COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
JUDE ALAWA GRADUATES WITH
DISTINCTION IN THE GLOBAL
AFFAIRS MAJOR, WITH A SECOND
MAJOR IN MOLECULAR, CELLULAR,
AND DEVELOPMENTAL BIOLOGY, AND
AS A GLOBAL HEALTH STUDIES
SCHOLAR.
JUDE IS DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING HEALTHCARE TO
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
HE IS THE FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR
OF SAHHA WA SALAAM, A NON-PROFI
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES
HUMANITARIAN ASSISTANCE TO
SYRIAN REFUGEES ACROSS THE
MIDDLE EAST.
AS PRESIDENT OF THE YALE
ROTARACT CLUB, HE HAS SUPPORTED
REFUGEE POPULATIONS AND LOCAL
UNDERSERVED RESIDENTS.
AND IN NEW HAVEN, HE HAS
VOLUNTEERED HIS TIME AT THE
HAVEN FREE CLINIC PROVIDING
HEALTH SERVICES TO UNINSURED
PATIENTS, AND TEACHING AND
TUTORING STUDENTS IN LOCAL
SCHOOLS.
AS A SCHOLAR, JUDE ALREADY HAS
LIST OF PUBLICATIONS, WITH
ARTICLES IN PRINT AND
FORTHCOMING ON CANCER TREATMENT
IN DISPLACED POPULATIONS,
REFUGEE HEALTH, AND COMMUNITY
HEALTH CARE.
HE HAS RECEIVED MULTIPLE
AWARDS AND FELLOWSHIPS IN
SUPPORT OF HIS RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY, INCLUDING THE
FULBRIGHT SCHOLARSHIP AND THE
FOX INTERNATIONAL FELLOWSHIP.
NEXT YEAR, HE WILL BEGIN A
MASTER'S OF PUBLIC HEALTH AT THE
CAMBRIDGE UNIVERSITY.
FOR HIS DEDICATION TO PUBLIC
SERVICE AT HOME AND ABROAD, YAL
COLLEGE IS PROUD TO BESTOW THE
JAMES ANDREW HAAS MEMORIAL PRIZ
UPON JUDE ALRAHMAN ALAWA.
[ APPLAUSE ]
JACLYN PRICE: HI EVERYONE, I'M.
JONATHAN SALAZAR: AND I'M
ONTHAN.
JACLYN: AND WE'LL BE INTRODUCI
SOME OF THE CLASS DAY
TRADITIONS.
JONATHAN: BEGINNING IN 1851,
EACH GRADUATING CLASS HAS LAID
AN IVY PLANT SOMEWHERE ON YALE'
CAMPUS, SYMBOLIZING THE ENDURIN
NATURE OF THE FRIENDSHIPS MADE
IN THE PAST FOUR YEARS. THIS
YEAR, OUR CLASS IVY WILL BE
PLACED RIGHT OUTSIDE OF PHELPS
GATE, UNDERNEATH A STONE CARVING
OF THE CLASS OF THE YEAR OF
2019.
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS WHO WAL
THROUGH PHELPS GATE AND ENTER
YALE COLLEGE, THE IVY AND THE
STONE WILL BE SYMBOLS OF THE
RESILIENCE AND STRENGTH OUR
CLASS FOUND HERE.
JACLYN: NOW, IF YOU LOOK IN TH
BAG UNDERNEATH YOUR CHAIR,
YOU'LL FIND A CLAY PIPE AND SOME
BUBBLES.
THE PIPE IS KNOWN AS THE
CHURCHWARDEN PIPE, AND IT'S BEE
GIVEN TO GRADUATING SENIORS
SINCE 1869.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, IF THIS WERE
1869 YALE CLASS DAY, THINGS
WOULD LOOK A LOT DIFFERENT: WE'D
BE SITTING IN A BIG CIRCLE,
WEARING TWEED JACKETS AND
SMOKING TOBACCO OUT OF THESE
PIPES.
NOW WE SIT TOGETHER ON OLD
CAMPUS, WEAR FUNNY HATS, AND
BLOW BUBBLES.
STILL, THE TRADITION OF THE
CHURCHWARDEN PIPE HAS ENDURED
FOR NEARLY 150 YEARS.
JONATHAN: A LOT OF TIME HAS
PASSED.
AND YALE NO LONGER LOOKS THE W
IT ONCE DID.
THE YALIES OF NOW DON'T LOOK
LIKE THE YALIES OF THE 1800'S.
BUT THE PLANTING OF THE IVY AND
THE CHURCHWARDEN PIPE ARE TWO
TRADITIONS THAT UNITE
GENERATIONS OF YALE GRADUATES.
JACLYN: TO SPEAK MORE ABOUT
CHANGE AT YALE IN ALL ITS FORMS
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
LARRY FULTON AND HIS CLASS
REFLECTION, "HOW TO SPOT A YALI"
[ APPLAUSE ]
LARRY FULTON: GOOD AFTERNOON.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE I HAVE ANY
NOTES UP HERE.
WHERE'S MOHAMMAD AT?
HEY!
THAT'S MY FRIEND MOHAMMAD.
I'M GOING TO OUT HIM FOR A
SECOND.
HE THINKS THAT HE CAN SPOT A
YALIE ANYWHERE.
HE SAID, "I SAW THE WHIFFENPOO
IN BEIJING."
DIDN'T YOU SAY THAT?
YEAH, YOU DID.
YOU DID.
MAKE MESS WONDER -- HOW DID HE
KNOW THAT IT WAS THE WHIFFS?
HOW DID HE KNOW THAT IT WAS THE
WHIFFS?
YOU KNOW, MAYBE IT WAS AS EASY
AS ASKING SOMEONE THEIR
RESIDENTIAL COLLEGE.
WHAT WAS THEIR FAVORITE SANDWICH
AT ALPHA DELTA?
DID THEY TAKE A CLASS CALLED THE
GOOD LIFE AND -- OR IS IT
SOMETHING ELSE ENTIRELY THAT
BINDS YALIES TOGETHER?
BUT WHAT IS THAT SOMETHING?
AND WHAT DOES IT HAVE TO DO NOT
JUST WITH EVERYONE WHO IS HERE
IN THE AUDIENCE TODAY, BUT WITH
THE THOUSANDS OF YALIES WHO HAVE
OCCUPIED THIS UNIVERSITY BEFORE
US.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CHANGE A
YALE EVEN IN OUR FOUR YEARS. TWO
NEW COLLEGES.
HOPPER.
FRESHMEN ARE NOW FIRST YEARS.
SORRY WE'RE AT -- SORRY, JE
SUCKS.
FRESHMEN ARE NOW FIRST YEARS.
MASTERS ARE HEADS OF COLLEGE.
NEXT YEAR ANYONE CAN LIVE IN
GENDER-NEUTRAL HOUSING IF THEY
SO CHOOSE.
AND AUDITION FOR THE WHIFFENPO.
BUT THIS COMES AS NO SURPRISE
YALE HAS ALWAYS BEEN A PLACE
THAT'S EMBRACED SHARP
DIFFERENCES IN OPINION, WHERE
BIG IDEAS HAVE CLASHED.
WE ARE, AFTER ALL, THE SCHOOL
JOHN ASHCROFT AND JOHN KERRY.
BILL BUCKLEY AND BILL COVEN.
WE MAY HAVE BEEN RIGHT OR WRONG,
LEFT OR RIGHT, BUT WE HAVE
CERTAINLY ALWAYS BEEN ENGAGEED.
AND IT IS THROUGH THIS CLASH,
THIS PUSH OF IDEAS AGAINST EACH
OTHER, AT YALE, THAT CHANGE HAS
BEEN BORN.
AT THE HEIGHT OF THE GREAT
DEPRESSION THE S.A.T. WAS
ESTABLISHED TO PROVIDE MORE
STUDENTS STUDENTS TO ATTEND
UNIVERSITIES LIKE YALE.
THEN ON CAMPUS, YALE'S STUDENT
BODY STARTED TO CHALLENGE THE
UNIVERSITY TO PAY ITS WORKERS
MORE.
WHILE AALUMNI WROTE LETTERS
OPPOSING POINTLESS NEW LAW
SCHOOL COURSES IN ECONOMICS AND
POLICY.
30 YEARS LATER, IN 1969, YALE
ADMITTED ITS FIRST CLASS OF
WOMEN.
IT WAS THAT SAME YEAR THAT THIS
CAMPUS ERUPTED AS A BATTLEGROUND
OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
FOR A YEAR, BLACK PANTHERS BOB
SEALE AND ERICKA HUGGINS STOOD
TRIAL IN NEW HAVEN.
THOUSANDS OF PROTESTORS FLOODED
THE GREEN.
AND YET YALE PRESIDENT KINGMAN
BREWSTER INSISTED ON OPENING
CAMPUS.
DINING HALLS PROVIDED MEALS, A
STUDENTS PROVIDED HOUSING TO
PEOPLE WHO HAD COME TO SPEAK
THEIR TRUTH.
THEN FOUR YEARS AGO, YALE
ADMITTED THE CLASS OF 201937 ITS
MOST DIVERSE CLASS OF STUDENTS
EVER.
AND THE TIMES TRIED TO ACT LIKE
WE WERE YALE'S FIRST RODEO.
I DON'T THINK SO.
THERE HAS ALWAYS BEEN
DISAGREEMENT AND DEBATE HERE,
WHAT BINDS US AS YALIES ISN'T
THE SPECIFIC CONTROVERSIES. IT'S
THE TRAINING IN ANALYTICAL
THINKING.
THE INSTRUCTION TO VALUE EMPAT
AND EMOTIONAL INTELLIGENCE AND
DIFFERENCE IN OPINION.
IT'S LEARNING FROM WATCHING OU
FRIENDS IN SCHOLARSHIP AND THE
REALMS OF MUSIC, ART, THEATER,
ARCHITECTURE -- THAT NOT
EVERYTHING THAT COUNTS CAN BE
COUNTED, WHILE NOT ALL THAT CAN
BE COUNTED REALLY COUNTS.
AND MORE THAN THAT THERE IS AN
ETHOS HERE - A SPIRIT OF
ACKNOWLEDGMENT - AMONG ALL THOS
WHO MAY DISAGREE.
CLICHÉ AS IT MAY BE, YALIES
STRIVE TO ENGAGE IN THE WORLD
AND TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE. IT'S
SIMPLY IN THE AIR HERE. FOR ME,
THAT'S YALE.
THIS WEIRD, ROWDY BUNCH OF KIDS
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD TOGETHER
IN ONE PLACE.
COMMITTED TO LUX ET VERITAS AND
COMMITTED TO EACH OTHER AND A
THIS THEY CAN DO ANYTHING.
IN 1939, YALIES RICH AND POOR
REDEFINED THE ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT.
IN 1969, YALIES MALE AND FEMAL
OF ALL COLORS HELD THIS
COUNTRY'S LEGAL SYSTEM
ACCOUNTABLE. IN 2019 NOW WE ARE
INSEPARABLE ISOLATIONISTS,
UNDOCUMENTED MODEL-CITIZENS,
SPIRITUAL ATHEISTS,
STOIC REVOLUTIONARIES,
TOMBOYISH GUYS, PRESIDENTIAL
PRE-MEDS.
AND IT'S ANYONE'S GUESS WHAT OR
LEGACY WILL MANIFEST.
ONE THING IS CERTAIN.
YALE IS NOT NAIVE IN CHOOSING A
CLASS.
WHEN THIS PLACE HAS CHOSEN TO
OPEN ITS DOORS TO MORE OF US, TO
NEW TYPES AND NEW BREEDS,
HISTORY HAS BEEN MADE.
AND THIS TIME AROUND, THEY CHOSE
US.
THEY CHOSE US TO ENGINEER A
SOLUTION TO CLIMATE CHANGE. TO
KEEP DESTRUCTIVE WEAPONS OUT OF
THE WRONG HANDS.
THEY CHOSE US TO BUILD AN
INCLUSIVE WORLD IN WHICH KIDS
DON'T HAVE TO COME TO A PLACE
LIKE YALE FOR A FAIR CHANCE AND
AN EQUAL SHOT.
[ APPLAUSE ]
SO, WITH ALL OF THAT I REPEATED
MY QUESTION TO MOHAMMAD.
I ASKED, HOW COULD YOU SPOT THE
WHIFFENPOOFS IN BEIJING?
HUSBAND ANSWER, WELL, THEY WALK
AROUND IN BOW TIES.
FAIR ENOUGH.
SOME OF US ARE PRETTY EASY TO
SPOT, ESPECIALLY TODAY.
WHAT'S IN HERE?
SPEAKING OF DEAN CHUN, PRESIDENT
SALOVEY, ESTEEMED FACULTY AND
STAFF.
LOVED ONES, FAMILY MEMBERS,
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING.
YOU CHALLENGED US, CERTAINLY,
BUT ALLOWED US TO DO THE SAME.
THROUGHOUT, YOU WERE FIRM IN
YOUR VALUES, TELLING US THAT WE
WOULD MAKE IT HERE.
THROUGH THE TEARS, ANXIETIES,
SCIENCE AND WRITING CREDITS.
TODAY IS PROOF THAT TOGETHER WE
COULD MAKE IT.
AND TO MY FELLOW GRADUATES OF
-- AND FRIENDS IN THE CLASS OF
2019: WE WERE ACCOMPANIED HERE
BY A WAVE OF CHANGE.
THEN WE ELECTED AN ALDER,
WE FOUNDED EVERY VOTE COUNTS.
WE PROVED THAT SOME PEOPLE DO
HAVE SUPERPOWERS.
AND WE LEARNED THE WORLD OVER.
BECAUSE LIKE YALIES FROM MANY
GENERATIONS, WE DON'T SIMPLY
STUDY HISTORY.
YOU SPOT A YALIE AT THE EDGE OF
HISTORY.
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
PUSHING THE BOUNDARIES AND
LEAVING A LEGACY.
HERE'S TO YOU, CLASS OF 2019.
FOR THE PAST FOUR YEARS AND FOR
THE LIFETIME COMMITMENT TO
SERVICE AND TO HUMANITY THAT WE
WILL CARRY WITH US OUT INTO THE
BROADER WORLD.
THANK YOU AND CONGRATULATIONS.
[ APPLAUSE ]
MARVIN CHUN: SO, HERE'S HOW TO
SPOT A YALIE.
A YALIE IS A STUDENT WHO IS MORE
ERUDITE AND ELOQUENT THAN THEIR
DEAN.
GREAT JOB.
LILY SPARROW MIRFAKHRAIE, WILL
YOU PLEASE COME UP TO THE STAGE?
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE WARREN MEMORIAL HIGH
SCHOLARSHIP PRIZE, FOR THE
SENIOR MAJORING IN THE
HUMANITIES WHO RANKS HIGHEST IN
SCHOLARSHIP, IS AWARDED THIS
YEAR TO LILY SPARROW MIRFAKHRAI
OF DAVENPORT COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
LILY IS A FIERCELY PROUD WEST
VIRGINIAN AND HEAD FIRST YEAR
COUNSELOR IN DAVENPORT COLLEGE.
BALANCING A DOUBLE MAJOR IN THE
HISTORY OF SCIENCE, MEDICINE AN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND MOLECULAR,
CELLULAR AND DEVELOPMENTAL
BIOLOGY, SHE WAS ELECTED TO PHI
BETA KAPPA IN HER SENIOR YEAR
AND GRADUATES SUMMA CUM LAUDE,
WITH DISTINCTION IN BOTH HER
MAJORS.
EVEN AS A FIRST-YEAR STUDENT,
LILY'S INSTRUCTORS COMMENTED ON
HER "UNUSUAL SENSITIVITY IN
DEALING WITH CHALLENGING
MATERIAL."
SHE BROUGHT THAT SAME
SENSITIVITY TO BEAR ON HER
SENIOR ESSAY WHICH EXPLORES THE
HISTORY OF COAL COMPANY
PHYSICIANS IN CENTRAL APPALACHI.
LILY IS THE RECIPIENT OF THE
Y-WORK AWARD IN RECOGNITION OF
HER OUTSTANDING CONTRIBUTIONS A
AN UNDERGRADUATE EMPLOYEE.
IN RECOGNITION OF HER
EXTRAORDINARY ACHIEVEMENTS, YALE
COLLEGE IS PROUD TO AWARD THE
WARREN MEMORIAL HIGH SCHOLARSH
PRIZE THIS YEAR TO LILY SPARROW.
[ APPLAUSE ]
HANNAH LAWRENCE, WILL YOU PLEA
COME UP TO THE STAGE?
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE RUSSELL HENRY CHITTENDEN
PRIZE IS AWARDED ANNUALLY FOR
THE SENIOR MAJORING IN THE
NATURAL SCIENCES OR IN
MATHEMATICS WHO RANKS HIGHEST IN
SCHOLARSHIP.
THIS YEAR'S PRIZE IS AWARDED T
HANNAH LOUISE LAWRENCE OF
DAVENPORT COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
HANNAH HAS DISTINGUISHED HERSE
AS A DOUBLE MAJOR IN APPLIED
MATHEMATICS AND COMPUTER
SCIENCE.
ELECTED TO PHI BETA KAPPA IN H
JUNIOR YEAR, HANNAH GRADUATES
SUMMA CUM LAUDE WITH DISTINCTION
IN BOTH HER MAJORS.
IN A FIELD THAT SELDOM CHANGES
ANSWER KEYS, HANNAH'S SENIOR
PROJECT ADVISER IN APPLIED
MATHEMATICS STATES THAT SHE
OFFERED A "SOLUTION THAT IS
BETTER THAN WHAT IS KNOWN FOR
THIS PROBLEM."
HANNAH HAS BALANCED HER
EXTRAORDINARY PERFORMANCE IN TH
CLASSROOM WITH HER PASSION FOR
MUSIC, PLAYING AS A DEVOTED
MEMBER OF THE YALE SYMPHONY
ORCHESTRA'S FIRST VIOLIN
SECTION.
HANNAH HAS ALSO CONTRIBUTED HE
TALENTS AS A MEMBER OF THE YALE
COLLEGE STUDENT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON SCIENTIFIC AND
QUANTITATIVE REASONING, ADVISI
THE YALE COLLEGE DEAN'S OFFICE
ON MATTERS RELATED TO
UNDERGRADUATE EDUCATION.
IN RECOGNITION OF HER COMMITME
TO ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE, YALE
COLLEGE PROUDLY AWARDS THE
RUSSELL HENRY CHITTENDEN PRIZE
TO HANNAH LOUISE LAWRENCE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
CAN YOU PLEASE COME UP TO THE
YOU PLEASE COME UP TO THE STAGE?
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE LOUIS SUDLER PRIZES, FOR
EXCELLENCE IN THE PERFORMING AN
CREATIVE ARTS, ARE AWARDED TO
TWO OUTSTANDING SENIORS.
EREN ORBEY IS A WRITER WHOSE
WORK SHOWS INTELLECTUAL RIGOR,
EMOTIONAL DEPTH, AND STYLISTIC
GRACE. WHILE DOUBLE-MAJORING IN
COMPUTER SCIENCE AND ENGLISH,
WITH A CONCENTRATION IN CREATIV
NONFICTION, EREN HAS CONTRIBUTE
EIGHTEEN ESSAYS AND PROFILES TO
THE NEW YORKER, WITH TOPICS
RANGING FROM PERSONAL HISTORY T
CONTEMPORARY PHOTOGRAPHY TO
WOMEN'S GYMNASTICS.
WITH COURAGE AND BEAUTY, HIS
CREATIVE THESIS, THE BASIS OF A
PLANNED BOOK-LENGTH MEMOIR,
ADDRESSED THE IMPACT OF A
DEVASTATING FAMILY TRAGEDY AND
ENTAILED TRAVEL TO ANKARA,
TURKEY; THE READING OF HUNDREDS
OF PAGES OF DEPOSITIONS, LEGAL
TRANSCRIPTS, AND POLICE REPORTS
AND PROFOUND SELF-EXAMINATION.
EREN GRADUATES MAGNA CUM LAUDE,
PHI BETA KAPPA, AND WITH
DISTINCTION IN BOTH OF HIS
MAJORS.
HE WILL PURSUE GRADUATE STUDIE
IN MODERN MIDDLE EASTERN STUDIE
AT OXFORD NEXT YEAR AS A RHODES
SCHOLAR.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ALEXIS "A.K." PAYNE IS AN
ACCOMPLISHED DRAMATIST WITH
ASTONISHING PROMISE.
A DOUBLE MAJOR IN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN STUDIES AND
ENGLISH, SHE GRADUATES WITH
DISTINCTION IN BOTH, AND WITH A
CONCENTRATION IN PLAYWRITING. IN
WORKS PRODUCED AT THE YALE
DRAMAT AND THE YALE PLAYWRIGHTS
FESTIVAL, A.K. HAS TRAINED HER
FIERCE MORAL VISION AND FINELY
TUNED EAR ON THE FRAUGHT AND
AUTHENTIC LIVES OF PEOPLE IN
REAL PLACES AND IN REAL
SITUATIONS, LAYING BARE THE
URGENT POETRY OF VOICES THAT, A
SHE MOVINGLY INSISTS, NEED TO B.
BE HEARD.
HER PLAYS ANIMATE THE
EXPERIENCES AND ASPIRATIONS OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR IN AMERICAN
HISTORY, AND HER MENTORS AND
PROFESSORS NOTE HER WORK'S DEEP
COMPASSION, HISTORICAL RESEARCH
AND POLITICAL URGENCY.
IN THE FALL, A.K. BEGINS THE M
PROGRAM IN PLAYWRITING AT THE
YALE SCHOOL OF DRAMA.
[ APPLAUSE ]
FOR HER EXCEPTIONAL
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ON THE PAGE AND
STAGE, AND FOR HER BRIGHT FUTUR
AHEAD, YALE COLLEGE IS HONORED
TO AWARD THE LOUIS SUDLER PRIZE
FOR EXCELLENCE IN THE PERFORMIN
AND CREATIVE ARTS TO A.K. PAYNE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
DEVYN RIGSBY OF PIERSON COLLEG
WILL YOU PLEASE COME UP TO THE ?
STAGE?
[ APPLAUSE ]
THE ARTHUR TWINING HADLEY PRIZ
WHICH HONORS THE MEMORY OF THE
MAN WHO SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF
YALE FROM 1899 TO 1921, IS
AWARDED ANNUALLY TO THE SENIOR
IN YALE COLLEGE MAJORING IN THE
SOCIAL SCIENCES WHO RANKS
HIGHEST IN SCHOLARSHIP.
THE ALPHEUS HENRY SNOW PRIZE I
AWARDED TO THAT "SENIOR WHO
THROUGH THE COMBINATION OF
INTELLECTUAL ACHIEVEMENT,
CHARACTER, AND PERSONALITY,
SHALL BE ADJUDGED BY THE FACULT
TO HAVE DONE THE MOST FOR YALE
BY INSPIRING IN HIS OR HER
CLASSMATES AN ADMIRATION AND
LOVE FOR THE BEST TRADITIONS OF
HIGH SCHOLARSHIP."
THIS YEAR, BOTH THE HADLEY AND
THE SNOW PRIZE ARE AWARDED TO
DEVYN CHRISTINE RIGSBY OF
PIERSON COLLEGE.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ELECTED TO PHI BETA KAPPA AFTE
JUST FOUR TERMS OF ENROLLMENT,
-- AND SHE HAS BEEN DEEPLY
INVOLVED
IN RESEARCH AND LEADERSHIP IN
GLOBAL AFFAIRS AND SCIENCES. SHE
HAS BEEN A U.S. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOREIGN LANGUAGE AND
AREA STUDIES FELLOW FOR ARABIC
AND THE MIDDLE EAST, AS WELL AS
A FELLOW FOR THE PEACE AND
DIALOGUE LEADERSHIP INITIATIVE.
SHE HAS ALSO SERVED AS A
LEGISLATIVE INTERN FOR THE STAT
OF ILLINOIS AND AS AN INTERN IN
THE EGYPTIAN CONSULATE OF
CHICAGO.
AND AS AN EXTENSION OF HER WOR
IN THE SCIENCES, DEVYN HAS BEEN
A RESEARCH ASSISTANT IN THE YAL
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
DEPARTMENT OF SURGERY AND
SURGICAL CRITICAL CARE.
DEVYN BRINGS THE SAME RIGOR AN
EXCELLENCE TO THE LEADERSHIP
ROLES SHE HAS HELD AS PRESIDENT
OF YALE'S PHI BETA KAPPA
CHAPTER, AND AS AN ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE YALE
COLLEGE COUNCIL SINCE THE FALL
OF 2015, FILLING THE ROLE OF
ACADEMIC POLICY DIRECTOR AND
CHIEF OF STAFF.
TAKEN TOGETHER, HER
ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND HER FIELDS
OF SCHOLARSHIP SHOW
EXTRAORDINARY PROMISE AS SHE
PREPARES FOR A LIFE OF SERVICE
IN GLOBAL HEALTH POLICY AND
REFUGEE HEALTHCARE IN THE ARAB
WORLD.
IN RECOGNITION OF HER
CONTRIBUTIONS TO HER FIELDS OF
SCHOLARSHIP, HER LOVE OF
LEARNING, AND HER DEDICATION TO
THE COMMON GOOD, YALE COLLEGE I
PROUD TO AWARD BOTH THE ALPHEUS
HENRY SNOW PRIZE AND THE ARTHUR
TWINING HADLEY PRIZE TO DEVYN
CHRISTINE RIGSBY.
[ APPLAUSE ]
MANASI PATWA: HI EVERYONE. MY
NAME IS MANASI. ANNALISE GRAVES:
AND MY NAME IS THATLISE.
MANASI: WE ARE TWO OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE CLASS DAY
COMMITTEE.
ANNALISE: BEFORE INTRODUCING T
NEXT SPEAKERS, WE WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SHARE TWO OTHE
CLASS DAY TRADITIONS.
MANASI: FIRST, WE WANTED TO
INTRODUCE YOU ALL TO AN
IMPORTANT TRADITION THAT YOU
WILL SEE TOMORROW DURING THE
COMMENCEMENT CEREMONIES. DURING
THE COMMENCEMENT PROCESSION THE
RECIPIENTS OF THE TOP FIVE
ACADEMIC PRIZES THAT WERE JUST
AWARDED BY DEAN CHUN WILL CARRY
AN OFFICIAL FLAG OR BANNER.
ANNALISE: THE WINNERS OF THE
WARREN MEMORIAL PRIZE, RUSSELL
HENRY CHITTENDEN PRIZE, ARTHUR
TWINING HADLEY PRIZE, SUDLER
PRIZE, AND ALPHEUS HENRY SNOW
PRIZE CARRY THE AMERICAN FLAG,
CONNECTICUT FLAG, YALE COLLEGE
BANNER, PRESIDENT'S BANNER, AND
YALE UNIVERSITY BANNER,
RESPECTIVELY.
MANASI: SECOND, WE WOULD LIKE
INTRODUCE YOU ALL TO A SPECIAL
ITEM YOU WILL GET TO TAKE HOME
WITH YOU.
SENIORS, IN YOUR CLASS DAY BAG
IS A BOOKLET THAT CONTAINS
REFLECTIONS, WORKS OF ART, AND
POETRY THAT CAPTURE OUR SHARED
YALE EXPERIENCE-WE CALL THIS TH
2019 CLASS ANTHOLOGY.
THESE PIECES WERE CREATED BY
STUDENTS, ADMINISTRATORS, AND
MEMBERS OF THE FACULTY WHO
WISHED TO SHARE INSIGHTS
REGARDING OUR CLASS.
OUR TEAM SELECTED PIECES THAT
FOUND TO BE EXCEPTIONALLY
REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR TIMES HER
AS STUDENTS-BOTH THE HAPPY
EXPERIENCES AND THE MORE
CHALLENGING ONES.
ANNALISE: AS THE ANTHOLOGY TEA
WE WENT INTO THIS PROJECT WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE IS
NO SUCH THING AS A SINGULAR YALE
EXPERIENCE.
WE PUT TOGETHER THIS COLLECTIO
WHICH ENCOMPASSES A VARIETY OF
PERSPECTIVES, AND WE HOPE YOU'L
TAKE THE TIME TO READ THROUGH I
AND REFLECT ON YOUR OWN FOUR
YEARS HERE.
YOU MIGHT BE SURPRISED AT THE
THEMES THAT TIE US TOGETHER.
MANASI: THIS YEAR, WE HAVE ALS
INCLUDED SEVERAL BLANK PAGES AT
THE BACK OF THE ANTHOLOGY.
FEEL FREE TO USE THIS SPACE FO
NOTES, YOUR OWN REFLECTIONS, OR
CLASSMATES' SIGNATURES.
REQUEST IS-NO "HAGS" COMMENTS.
"HAGS" COMMENTS. IT'S NOT HIGH
SCHOOL ANYMORE.
MANASI: NOW, IT IS OUR PLEASUR
TO INTRODUCE THE NEXT STUDENT
SPEECH, WHICH WILL BE
SIGNIFICANTLY FUNNIER THAN ANY
JOKES WE JUST TRIED TO MAKE.
ANNALISE: EACH YEAR, THE CLASS
DAY TEAM SELECTS ONE OR MORE
STUDENTS TO PROVIDE A
LIGHT-HEARTED REFLECTION ON OUR
YALE EXPERIENCE.
THIS YEAR'S SPEAKERS ARE
RAFFAELLA DONATICH AND JOHN ROS.
THEIR SPEECH IS TITLED, "VOWS
THE CLASS OF 2019."
MANASI: PLEASE JOIN US IN
WELCOMING THEM TO THE PODIUM.
[ APPLAUSE ]
JOHN ROSENBLUTH: PRESIDENT
SALOVEY, DEAN CHUN, BELOVED
FRIENDS AND FAMILIES, THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US HERE TODAY.
AND TO THE CLASS OF 2019.
RAFFAELLA:  YOU DID THAT! JOHN:
YOU DID THE HECK OUT OF THAT!
RAFFAELLA:  PAPERS? THEY WERE
JOHN: P-SETS WERE TURNED IN.
RAFFAELLA:  A LITTLE LATE. JOHN:
AND YOU DIDN'T FORGET YOUR
ADVISOR'S LAST NAME AT YOUR
MELLON FORUM. RAFFAELLA:  HEY,
YOU IN THE BACK?
I HOPE YOU'RE READY FOR THE
PULITZER PRIZE IN RADIO
JOURNALISM COMING AT YOU IN THE
NEXT 10 TO 12 YEARS!
JOHN: YOU IN THE FRONT? BOOM!
FOUNDER OF THE NEXT BIG
FAIR-TRADE, CBD COSMETICS BRAND
RAFFAELLA:  SITTING IN FRONT OF
US TODAY IS THE NEXT GENERATION
OF PROLIFIC WRITERS AND
THINKERS.
JOHN: CAPTAINS OF INDUSTRY,
ROBBER BARONS.
RAFFAELLA:  YOU'VE ALL ACHIEVE
SO MUCH, AND WE'RE SO PROUD TO
CALL YOU OUR CLASSMATES AND OUR.
FRIENDS.
BUT JOHN: BUT IF I'M NOT MISTAK
THERE'S A, UH, BIT OF AN
ELEPHANT IN THE QUAD, IF YOU
WILL.
RAFFAELLA:  OKAY, JOHN, YOU DO
KNOW THE EXPRESSION IS "ELEPHAN
IN THE ROOM."
JOHN: RAFFI, I KNOW, I'M JUST
TRYING TO ADAPT THAT IDIOM TO
CAMPUS LIFE. GOD!
RAFFAELLA:  ANYWAYS.
I'M JUST GONNA SORT OF TAKE A
MOMENT TO EMBRACE RADICAL
VULNERABILITY RIGHT NOW, YOU
KNOW IT IS 2019 AFTER ALL, OUR
GRADUATING YEAR, AND, I'M JUST
GONNA SAY IT: ROMANTICALLY, I'M
UNFULFILLED.
[ APPLAUSE ]
JOHN: FOUR YEARS OF DATING AT
YALE HAVE BEEN...EXCRUCIATINGLY
PAINFUL.
RAFFAELLA:  IT HAS BEEN,
HONESTLY, THE
MILITARY-INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX OF
ROMANCE.
JOHN: NOBODY KNOWS HOW IT WORK
SOMEBODY IS GETTING SO FREAKING
RICH, AND SOMEBODY'S GONNA GET
HURT.
SOMEBODY'S GOING TO GET HURT.
RAFFAELLA:  IT'S DATING IN THE
DIGITAL AGE.
JOHN: THE EMOTIONAL APPARATUS
THE CLASS OF 2019 HAS BEEN BLOW
APART BY NUCLEAR GRADE WEAPONRY
RAFFAELLA: AND AT AN INSTITUTIO
LIKE YALE THAT IS SO FOCUSED ON
SUCCESS, WE JUST WANT TO TAKE A
SECOND TO ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF
OUR FAILURES.
JOHN: YEAH, WE'VE ALL BEEN STOOD
UP BY A TINDER DATE AT WESLEYAN
BECAUSE SHE WAS PREPARING HER
FAKE DEAD HERMIT CRAB FOR A FAKE
BURIAL.
YES, THIS ACTUALLY HAPPENED,
AND, YES, I'M STILL UPSET ABOUT
IT.
RAFFAELLA: WE'VE ALL HAD A CRU
ON A TF, I DON'T KNOW, I'M NOT
LIKE THINKING ABOUT ANYONE
SPECIFICALLY RIGHT NOW, BUT
MAYBE IN THE CONTEMPORARY ART
HISTORY CLASS WE TOOK SOPHOMORE
SPRING, IN WHICH WE ACCIDENTALL
AND CONFIDENTLY SAID "I LOVE
YOU" TO THEM AT THE END OF
SECTION.
JOHN: DID THEY SAY IT BACK?
RAFFAELLA: YEAH, WE'RE ACTUALLY
MOVING TO BROOKLYN TOGETHER
AFTER GRADUATION.
OH, JEEZ, SERIOUSLY?
RAFFAELLA: OBVIOUSLY NOT. JOHN:
I'M SO SORRY. RAFFAELLA: AND,
YOU KNOW WHAT? I ALSO WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT A DYNAMIC THAT WE ALL
MISSED THE BOAT ON OUR PERSONAL.
RIGHT?
LIKE, YEAH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH.
LIKE, THEY WERE THE ONE PERSON
AT THIS UNIVERSITY WE COULD
COUNT ON TO RESPOND TO US IN A
PRODUCTIVE AND HEALTHY WAY.
JOHN: UM, ACTUALLY, MY PERSONAL
LIBRARIAN GHOSTED ME.
RAFFAELLA: ARE YOU SERIOUS?
JOHN: YEAH, I TOLD HER THAT
ORBIS ADVANCED SEARCH WAS
ANYTHING BUT AN INTUITIVE, USER
FRIENDLY, COMPREHENSIVE
DATABASE, AND SHE REFUSED TO
SPEAK TO ME AGAIN.
RAFFAELLA: YOU KNOW, THIS
CONVERSATION IS REALLY OPENING
UP A DEEP WELL OF REJECTION,
FRUSTRATION, AND PERSONAL PAIN.
JOHN: HONESTLY, SAME.
DO YOU REMEMBER OUR VERY FIRST
WEEK ON CAMPUS?
RAFFAELLA: CAMP YALE? JOHN:
MORE LIKE CAMP FAIL AMIRITE?
RAFFAELLA: WE'LL WORKSHOP THAT
JOHN: ANYWAY, SUE ME, BUT I WAS
UNPLEASANTLY SURPRISED WHEN I
LEARNED THAT "WALKING ON TO THE
FOOTBALL TEAM" DIDN'T MEAN THAT
I COULD JUST SIMPLY WALK ONTO
THE FIELD AND BE WELCOMED INTO
BROTHERHOOD OF STRONG, VIRILE,
AND PLAYFUL MEN. [ LAUGHTER ]
RAFFAELLA: YEAH, I THINK WE AL
REALIZE THAT YALE IS GUILTY OF
SOME PRETTY FALSE ADVERTISING.
WE ARRIVE ON MOVE-IN DAY,
EQUIPPED WITH OUR TWIN XL
SHEETS, READY TO TAKE RISKS AND
EXPLORE ALL OF THE AMAZING
OPPORTUNITIES WE WERE PROMISED.
JOHN: LITTLE DID WE KNOW, THAT
TO WORK IN A COLLEGE BUTTERY,
YOU HAVE TO HAVE EARNED A
MICHELIN STAR.
I'M JUST LIKE, I KNOW HOW TO P
A DINO NUGGET IN A MICROWAVE.
RAFFAELLA: YEAH, TO GET ACCEPTE
INTO PROFESSOR ANNE FADIMAN'S
ILLUSTRIOUS WRITING SEMINAR,
"WRITING ABOUT ONESELF," YOU
HAVE TO HAVE WRITTEN MOBY DICK.
AND BECAUSE THE CLASS IS ABOUT
THE MEMOIR, YOU, IN FACT, HAVE
TO HAVE BEEN A SPERM WHALE.
JOHN: SPEAKING OF WHALES: IN
HIGH SCHOOL, WE WERE BIG FISH IN
SMALL PONDS.
THEN AWAY CAME TO YALE AND WE
FIGURED OUT WE WERE ACTUALLY
SMALL FISH ON A REALLY BIG
FOOTBALL TEAM.
RAFFAELLA: I'LL SAY IT: BEING
GAINFULLY ENROLLED AT THIS
UNIVERSITY CAN BE STRESSFUL.
JOHN: AND THE WAY YALIES DEAL
WITH STRESS IS HONESTLY KIND OF
UNHINGED.
RAFFAELLA: YEAH, I THINK IT'D
GOOD FOR ALL OF US TO RECOGNIZE
NAKED PARTIES AS ONE OF THE MOS
BIZARRE, HIGH-MAINTENANCE,
NOT-LOW-KEY TRADITIONS IN THE
HISTORY OF HUMAN TRADITIONS.
JOHN: "HI, IT'S JOHN FROM DAIL.
THEMES.
I'M NOT WEARING ANY CLOTHES
EAT.
HOW ARE YOU?
I'M INCREDIBLY ANXIOUS."
RAFFAELLA: WE ARE AWARE THAT
THERE ARE PARENTS IN THE
AUDIENCE.
JOHN: WE ARE ALSO AWARE THAT
SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE MET AT
YALE.
RAFFAELLA: AND WE HATE THAT.
JOHN: YEAH. REALLY NOT COOL,
GUYS.
RAFFAELLA: THE EXPECTATION OF
FINDING YOUR SPOUSE AT YALE IS
TOO MUCH PRESSURE. AND NOT THE
POINT.
JOHN: LIKE, I'M TRYING TO WRIT
A 5 TO 8-PAGER ON INFLATION IN
THE WEIMAR REPUBLIC, ALL RIGHT?
I CAN'T BE EXPECTED TO THINK
ABOUT RAISING A FAMILY.
RAFFAELLA: YEAH, I'M JUST TRYIN
TO INTENTIONALLY AND
THOUGHTFULLY UTILIZE MY DURFEE
SWIPE.
I'M IN ABSOLUTELY NO PLACE TO
GET MARRIED.
JOHN: SOME OF US WILL END UP
MARRYING SOMEONE IN OUR FROCO
GROUP.
RAFFAELLA: OTHERS OF US WILL
NOT.
JOHN: BECAUSE, SERIOUSLY,
COLLEGE IS WEIRD.
THEY THROW US ONTO THE FIFTH
FLOOR OF L-DUB -- THERE IT IS.
THERE IT IS.
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN WE HAVE
TO WEAR FLIP-FLOPS IN THE SHOWER
FOR LEGITIMATE HEALTH CONCERNS.
AND WE'RE EXPECTED TO FIND OUR
SOUL MATES.
RAFFAELLA: AND MY DEAN IS
SERIOUSLY TRYING TO TELL ME THA
THAT DOESN'T FULFILL MY SOCIAL
SCIENCE DISTRIBUTIONAL REQUIREM?
JOHN:  RAFFI IS CREDIT-DEFICIE
AND WILL BE RETURNING IN THE
FALL.
RAFFAELLA: THAT IS NOT
INCORRECT.
JOHN: WELL, I THINK WE CAN ALL
SAFELY SAY THAT WE GAVE DATING
IN THE DIGITAL AGE THE OLD
COLLEGE TRY.
RAFFAELLA: GET IT? CUZ WE'RE
ALL GRADUATING COLLEGE RIGHT
NOW.
JOHN: THAT WAS A PLAY ON WORDS
BASED ON THE SITUATION.
RAFFAELLA: BUT CAN I GET REAL
FOR A SECOND?
JOHN: YEAH, DO IT, DO IT, DO I,
DO IT.
RAFFAELLA: EVEN THOUGH COLLEGE
HAS NOT YIELDED ME MY LIFE
PARTNER, I AM GRADUATING RIGHT
NOW WITH SOME PRACTICE TAKING
CARE OF THE PEOPLE I LOVE. JOHN
: YEAH, I MEAN, TALK ABOUT "IN
SICKNESS AND IN HEALTH," YOU
SHOULD HAVE SEEN MY ROOMMATE GO
FULL GREY'S ANATOMY WHEN I GOT
STREPTOCOCCAL PHARYNGITIS.
RAFFAELLA: YOU MEAN STREP
THROAT?
JOHN: YEAH, THAT'S WHAT I SAID
"STREPTOCOCCAL PHARYNGITIS."
RAFFAELLA: ALTHOUGH WE'RE
LEAVING CAMPUS AND DISPERSING
ALL OVER THE WORLD, THE BOTTOM
LINE IS: 'TIL DEATH DO US PART.
JOHN: YALE CLASS OF 2019, THIS
IS PRETTY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
COMMUNICATE, BUT...
RAFFAELLA: WE'VE ACTUALLY HAD
FEELINGS FOR YOU FOR KIND OF A
LONG TIME.
WE DIDN'T WANT TO SAY ANYTHING
IN CASE IT INTERFERED WITH THIS
REALLY AMAZING FRIENDSHIP THING
WE'VE GOT GOING.
JOHN: BUT, THERE'S NO POINT
PRETENDING NOW.
YOU'RE THE ONE THAT GOT AWAY.
RAFFAELLA: WANNA GET A MEAL?
JOHN: OR GO TO THE YUAG ON
SATURDAY MORNING? RAFFAELLA: WE
ACTUALLY HAVE KIND OF INCREDIBL
JOHN: I FEEL LIKE THIS GETTING
KIND OF SERIOUS.
RAFFAELLA: ARE WE EXCLUSIVE,
OR?
JOHN: DO YOU WANT TO MEET MY
PARENTS?
THEY'LL PAY FOR DINNER.
RAFFAELLA: I THINK WE SHOULD
MOVE IN TOGETHER.
JOHN: LET'S START WITH A BETA
FISH AND THEN WE CAN CONSIDER
GETTING A DOG.
RAFFAELLA: I JUST FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE NOT LISTENING TO ME!
JOHN: I'M NOT WILLING TO GIVE UP
ON US.
RAFFAELLA: I CAN'T HOLD THIS IN
ANY LOPPINGER.
WILL YOU MARRY ME?
JOHN: I LOVE YOU MORE NOW THAN
I'VE EVER LOVED YOU BEFORE.
RAFFAELLA: YOU LOOK SO BEAUTIFUL
IN WHITE.
JOHN: I CAN'T BELIEVE WE'RE
HAVING TWINS!
RAFFAELLA: YALE WILL NAME THEM
BENJAMIN AND FRANKLIN. JOHN:
2019, I WOULDN'T WANT TO GROW
OLD WITH ANYONE ELSE. RAFFAELLA:
AND WOULDN'T WANT TO GRADUATE
WITH ANYONE ELSE. TOGETHER:
HERE'S TO THE CLASS OF 2019!
[ APPLAUSE ]
SONNY STEPHENS: HELLO CLASS OF
2019!
I'M SONNY STEPHENS.
MAYA RODRIGUEZ: I'M MAYA
RODRIGUEZ.
NICK GIRARD: AND I'M NICK
GIRARD.
SONNY: WE WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
ONE FINAL SET OF CLASS DAY
TRADITIONS AND THEN INTRODUCE
OUR FINAL STUDENT SPEAKER. THE
CLASS REFLECTIONS ARE LEGACIES
OF THE DAYS WHEN YALE STUDENTS
DELIVERED FORMAL ACADEMIC
SPEECHES DURING THIS CEREMONY.
TODAY, WE CARRY ON THIS
TRADITION WITH THE TWO SHORT
SETS OF REMARKS ABOUT THE YALE
EXPERIENCE YOU HEARD FROM LARRY
FULTON, RAFFI DONATICH, AND JOHN
ROSENBLUTH.
SPEAKERS AUDITION BEFORE THE
CLASS DAY COMMITTEE AND ARE
SELECTED BASED ON HOW THEIR
PIECES REFLECT OUR FOUR YEARS.
SPEECHES THAT SHOW OUR
RESILIENCE AND GRIT, BUT ALSO TO
SHOW OUR ABILITY TO HAVE FUN.
ALONGSIDE THESE REFLECTIONS, T
CLASS HISTORY HAS TAKEN MANY
FORMS OVER THE YEARS TO TELL TH
STORY OF OUR TIME AT YALE. IN
KEEPING UP WITH MODERN
TECHNOLOGY AND WITH THE INTENT
TO PROVIDE AS MUCH STUDENT INPUT
INTO THE CLASS HISTORY AS
POSSIBLE, DURING THE SINGING O
"BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS" YOU WILL
SEE A CURATION OF PHOTOS THAT
THE CLASS OF 2019 HAS SUBMITTED
TO BE DISPLAYED BEFORE US. MAYA:
"'BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS' WAS
WRITTEN IN 1881 BY HENRY DURAND
AND HAS BEEN THE UNOFFICIAL ALMA
MATER OF YALE SINCE.
SUNG AT REUNIONS, FOOTBALL
GAMES, AND CLASS DAY, IT REMAIN
A SYMBOL OF YALE'S TRADITIONS
AND LONG, LONG HISTORY.
ON THE LAST LINES OF THE SONG,
WE RAISE HANDKERCHIEFS-IF YOU
LOST YOURS FROM FRESHMAN YEAR,
THE YALE ALUMNI ASSOCIATION HAS
GENEROUSLY PROVIDED NEW ONES-AN
WAVE THEM ALONG, AS YEARS OF
GRADUATING CLASSES HAVE BEFORE
US, SINGING "FOR GOD, FOR
COUNTRY, AND FOR YALE."
NICK: THE ORIGINAL IVY ODE FOR
THE CLASS OF 1852, COMPOSED IN
LATIN SAPPHIC STANZAS, DESCRIBE
A SYMBOLIC CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE GROWTH OF THE IVY VINE AND
THE FLOURISHING OF THE
GRADUATING CLASS.
LATIN VERSE HAS GIVEN WAY TO A
ORIGINAL SPOKEN WORD OR LYRICAL
PERFORMANCE BY A MEMBER OF THE
GRADUATING CLASS, BUT THE
PURPOSE REMAINS THE SAME.
THE LONG-FORGOTTEN SECOND VERS
OF "BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS"
DESCRIBES HOW, JUST AS THE IVY
TWINES AROUND THE OAK, SO TOO
ARE OUR HEARTS BOUND TO YALE BY
TIES OF LOVE.
THE IVY ODE IS A MESSAGE OF
RESILIENCE AND FLOURISHING, A
CELEBRATION OF WHO WE HAVE BEE
AT YALE AND THE LIFETIME AHEAD
AS GRADUATES OF THIS UNIVERSITY
THE 2019 IVY ODE-ENTITLED "ALL
OUR NAMES"-IS WRITTEN AND WILL
BE DELIVERED BY ASHIA AJANI. [
APPLAUSE ]
"BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS" WILL
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOW. PLEASE
WELCOME ASHIA.
[ APPLAUSE ]
ASHIA AJANI:  THE FIRST TIME W
WALKED ON THIS CAMPUS
THE GATES CRIED OPEN AND
WELCOMED OUR EAGER SMILES
YOUTHFUL EXUBERANCE BREATHING
LIFE INTO THIS ARCHAIC WALLS
MANY OF US PERFECTED OUR
ELEVATOR PITCHES DURING FOOT OR
CULTURAL CONNECTIONS SOME COMBED
THROUGH QUINNIPIAC SOIL DURING
HARVEST, LEARNED HOW TO SAY
"WELCOME" IN FIVE DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES DURING OIS FOCUSED ON
WHO MAKES NEW HAVEN GREAT, AND
WHEN WE ALL CAME FOR ORIENTATION
THE WORLD MELTED INTO A OASIS
UNFAMILIAR TO MANY A VOICE SAID,
"THIS CAN BE YOUR HOME TOO" --
AND WE READILY ACCEPTED.
ACCEPTED.
AND THIS IS NO EASY TASK, HOME
BUILDING
THIS CREATION WILL ASK YOU TO
BARE YOUR SOUL.
TO VIEW YOURSELF IN NEW WAYS
UNEXPLORED AND UNCOMFORTABLE AND
WE ROSE TO THE TASK.
SOMEONE PUT FLOWERS IN YOUR HA
DURING SPRING FLING AND TOLD YO
YOU WERE BEAUTIFUL.
FINALLY, YOU HAD A PROFESSOR W
LOOKED LIKE YOU.
WHO REMINDED YOU WHY YOU CAME TO
THIS CAMPUS.
YOU WON A MOCK TRIAL TOURNAMEN
YOU GOT YOUR HEART BROKEN.
YOU WROTE AN ANGRY LOVE POEM.
YOU FINALLY TOLD OFF THAT ONE
ARROGANT PERSON IN SEMINAR. YOU
WERE, UNWITTINGLY, THAT ONE
SHED A DEAD NAME AND HONORED THE
ARROGANT PERSON IN SEMINAR. YOU
RIGHT VERSION OF YOURSELF
SHED A DEAD NAME AND HONORED THE
WITH CORRECT PRONOUNS AND A NE
RIGHT VERSION OF YOURSELF
VIBRANT SHADE OF LIPSTICK.
WITH CORRECT PRONOUNS AND A NE
YOU HELPED PUT ON A DRAG SHOW.
VIBRANT SHADE OF LIPSTICK.
YOU WATCHED TOO MANY MOVIES IN
YOU HELPED PUT ON A DRAG SHOW.
ONE SITTING, AND DEBATED WITH
YOU WATCHED TOO MANY MOVIES IN
YOUR SUITEMATES WHETHER OR NOT
ONE SITTING, AND DEBATED WITH
ZOOTOPIA WAS AN ALLEGORY FOR TH
YOUR SUITEMATES WHETHER OR NOT
POLICE STATE INTO THE SLANTED
ZOOTOPIA WAS AN ALLEGORY FOR TH
HOURS OF THE NIGHT.
POLICE STATE INTO THE SLANTED
ALL THE WHILE SMILING AND
HOURS OF THE NIGHT.
FALLING DEEPER IN LOVE WITH A
ALL THE WHILE SMILING AND
PLACE SO SEEMINGLY UNFAMILIAR.
FALLING DEEPER IN LOVE WITH A
HOW THE YEARS ASK US TO CONSIDER
PLACE SO SEEMINGLY UNFAMILIAR.
OURSELVES.
HOW THE YEARS ASK US TO CONSIDER
WHAT HAS CHANGED SINCE THOSE
OURSELVES.
FIRST DAYS?
WHAT HAS CHANGED SINCE THOSE
HOW OUR EYES AND HEARTS HAVE
FIRST DAYS?
SOFTENED.
HOW OUR EYES AND HEARTS HAVE
HOW WE HAVE GROWN INTO EVEN
SOFTENED.
BETTER VERSIONS OF OURSELVES.
HOW WE HAVE GROWN INTO EVEN
AND THAT DOES NOT COME WITHOUT
BETTER VERSIONS OF OURSELVES.
THIS RESPONSIBILITY TO ONE
AND THAT DOES NOT COME WITHOUT
ANOTHER.
THIS RESPONSIBILITY TO ONE
WHAT WILL WE MAKE OF OURSELVES
ANOTHER.
BEYOND THESE BRIGHT COLLEGE
WHAT WILL WE MAKE OF OURSELVES
YEARS?
BEYOND THESE BRIGHT COLLEGE
IN HER POEM "THE SUMMER DAY,"
YEARS?
THE LATE AMERICAN POET MARY
IN HER POEM "THE SUMMER DAY,"
OLIVER TAKES THE TIME TO OBSERVE
THE LATE AMERICAN POET MARY
AND REFLECT.
OLIVER TAKES THE TIME TO OBSERVE
PONDERS THE GRASSHOPPER, ASKS
AND REFLECT.
WHO MADE HER.
PONDERS THE GRASSHOPPER, ASKS
IN THIS POEM, OLIVER ASKS: WHAT
WHO MADE HER.
WE PLAN TO DO WITH OUR ONE WILD
IN THIS POEM, OLIVER ASKS: WHAT
AND PRECIOUS LIFE?
WE PLAN TO DO WITH OUR ONE WILD
OLIVER DOES NOT DEMAND THAT WE
AND PRECIOUS LIFE?
BLEED OURSELVES DRY, SEARCHING
OLIVER DOES NOT DEMAND THAT WE
FOR ADVENTURE.
BLEED OURSELVES DRY, SEARCHING
BUT THAT WE MARVEL AT THE MANY
FOR ADVENTURE.
STEPS WE HAVE TAKEN TO GET HERE
BUT THAT WE MARVEL AT THE MANY
AND THE ONES WE WILL TAKE AFTER
STEPS WE HAVE TAKEN TO GET HERE
CLASS OF 2019,
AND THE ONES WE WILL TAKE AFTER
WILL YOU LET THIS WORLD KNOW
CLASS OF 2019,
YOUR NAME IN ALL ITS ITERATIONS
WILL YOU LET THIS WORLD KNOW
WILL YOU TAKE TIME TO PONDER TH
YOUR NAME IN ALL ITS ITERATIONS
GRASSHOPPER WHEN THE EVILS OF
WILL YOU TAKE TIME TO PONDER TH
THIS WORLD TEMPT US INTO APATHY
GRASSHOPPER WHEN THE EVILS OF
AND IGNORANCE, WILL YOU REMEMBER
THIS WORLD TEMPT US INTO APATHY
THE LOVE THAT YOU FOUND HERE?
AND IGNORANCE, WILL YOU REMEMBER
THE LOVE THAT MADE YOU ASK FOR
THE LOVE THAT YOU FOUND HERE?
MORE AND DEMANDED THAT YOU NEVER
THE LOVE THAT MADE YOU ASK FOR
GIVE UP THIS FIGHT?
MORE AND DEMANDED THAT YOU NEVER
THE LOVE BORN FROM NEWNESS.
GIVE UP THIS FIGHT?
THROUGH LAUGHTER, THROUGH SONG.
THE LOVE BORN FROM NEWNESS.
THROUGH CHANT AND PROTEST AND
THROUGH LAUGHTER, THROUGH SONG.
RESILIENCE.
THROUGH CHANT AND PROTEST AND
WHAT LOVE HAVE YOU CARRIED FRO
RESILIENCE.
ALL OF YOUR DIFFERENT HOMES. TO
WHAT LOVE HAVE YOU CARRIED FRO
THIS NEW NORTHEASTERN ONE ON
ALL OF YOUR DIFFERENT HOMES. TO
THAT ONE NIGHT.
THIS NEW NORTHEASTERN ONE ON
YOU KNOW THE ONE.
THAT ONE NIGHT.
WHERE YOUR HOPE HAD FADED INTO
YOU KNOW THE ONE.
ALMOST NOTHING.
WHERE YOUR HOPE HAD FADED INTO
AND THE DUSK ASKED MORE OF YOU
ALMOST NOTHING.
THAN YOU COULD BEAR.
AND THE DUSK ASKED MORE OF YOU
A PRETTY GIRL BROUGHT YOU BOBA
THAN YOU COULD BEAR.
AND SAID "DO NOT GO QUIETLY."
A PRETTY GIRL BROUGHT YOU BOBA
THINK OF THE DAWN AND ALL THE
AND SAID "DO NOT GO QUIETLY."
HANDS THAT PUSHED YOU TOWARDS
THINK OF THE DAWN AND ALL THE
THIS MOMENT.
HANDS THAT PUSHED YOU TOWARDS
THINK OF THE WAYS WE WERE KIND
THIS MOMENT.
NOT ONLY TO OTHERS, BUT TO
THINK OF THE WAYS WE WERE KIND
OURSELVES.
NOT ONLY TO OTHERS, BUT TO
WE -- CARRIERS OF LIGHT AND
OURSELVES.
TRUTH -- LEAVE OUR MARK WHEREVER
WE -- CARRIERS OF LIGHT AND
WE GO.
TRUTH -- LEAVE OUR MARK WHEREVER
WHEN THE GATES CLOSE AND OUR
WE GO.
TIME HERE HAS DRAWN ITS LAST
WHEN THE GATES CLOSE AND OUR
BREATH, WHAT WILL THIS CAMPUS
TIME HERE HAS DRAWN ITS LAST
REMEMBER YOU BE?
BREATH, WHAT WILL THIS CAMPUS
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪
♪ BRIGHT COLLEGE YEARS, WITH
PLEASURE RIFE ♪
♪ THE SHORTEST, GLADDEST YEARS
OF LIFE ♪
♪ HOW SWIFTLY ARE YE GLIDING BY
♪
♪ OH, WHY DOTH TIME SO QUICKLY
FLY ♪
♪ THE SEASONS COME ♪
♪ THE SEASONS GO ♪
♪ THE EARTH IS GREEN OR WHITE
WITH SNOW ♪
♪ BUT TIME AND CHANGE SHALL
NAUGHT AVAIL ♪
♪ TO BREAK THE FRIENDSHIPS
FORMED AT YALE ♪
♪ IN AFTER YEARS SHOULD TROUBLES
RISE ♪
♪ TO CLOUD THE BLUE OF SUNNY
SKIES ♪
♪ HOW BRIGHT WILL SEEM THROUGH
MEM 'RY'S HAZE THOSE HAPPY
GOLDEN BYGONE DAYS ♪
♪ OH LET US STRIVE THAT EVER WE
MAY LET THESE WORDS OUR WATCH-
CRY BE ♪
♪ WHERE'ER UPON LIFE'S SEA WE
SAIL ♪
♪ FOR GOD, FOR COUNTRY AND FOR
YALE ♪
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> CONGRATULATIONS, EVERYONE.
CLASS DAY IS NOW COMPLETED.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> YOU MADE IT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING AND
HAVE A WONDERFUL EVENING.
[ APPLAUSE ]
♪